well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs damascus this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types from all different industries
areas of expertise my guest today back
by popular request
is jim collins jim collins is a student
and teacher of what makes great
companies tick
and a socratic advisor we'll explain
what that means to leaders throughout
the business and social sectors
his first appearance on this podcast was
easily one of the most
popular of all of 2019. people went
bananas so the hope is that we
bottle some of that lightning again in
this round too and we cover a lot
of new ground for those who don't know
jim jim has invested more than 25 years
in rigorous research and has authored or
co-authored six books
that have sold more than 10 million
copies worldwide in total they include
good to great the number one bestseller
that examines why some companies make
the leap to superior results
and its companion work good to great and
the social sectors
the enduring classic built to last many
of you will know that which explores how
some leaders build companies that remain
visionary for generations
how the mighty fall just in some ways
the exact opposite which delves into how
once great companies can self-destruct
and great by choice which is about
thriving in chaos
why some do and others don't and now
he's updated his debut book
beyond entrepreneurship for the 21st
century beyond
entrepreneurship 2.0 is the title
subtitle turning your business into an
enduring great company
is the subtitle is available now
everywhere books
are sold lesser known and as a teaser
for those who didn't pick this up in the
first episode
jim has been an avid rock climber for
more than 40 years and has completed
single-day ascents of el capitan and
half dome in yosemite valley
those of you in rock climbing will know
just how serious those accomplishments
are and he has many other interests many
other skills
and is an all-around fascinating
character so without further ado
jim collins jimcons.com is where you can
find all things jim
please enjoy this return of the
reclusive polymath
jim collins
this episode is brought to you by
givewell.org
tis the season of giving isn't it and
you've got a few weeks left to make your
charitable donations before we close the
books on 2020.
this is why i encourage you to check out
givewell.org for more than 10 years
givewell.org has helped donors find the
charities and projects that save
and improve lives most per dollar here's
how
givewell dedicates more than 20 000
hours a year to researching charitable
organizations
and hand-picks a few of the highest
impact evidence-backed
charities i recommend to givewell.org
and they shared a note with me
which is just incredible and here it is
quote here are the data they sent me a
spreadsheet we have from organic
donations that cited tim over the past
few years
transactions that specifically cited tim
ferriss sum to 133
040.74 cents we estimate that those
donations will save
15 to 24 lives how did this happen
i suspect that a lot of these donations
came from my interview with will
mccaskill
who really knows what he's talking about
when it comes to effective giving he's a
philosopher
ethicist and one of the originators of
the effective altruism movement
he is an associate professor in
philosophy at oxford
that is the university of oxford and a
researcher at the global priorities
institute at oxford just a great guy
overall
and in our podcast together he
recommended givewell
by far as one of the best places to give
if you want to make an impact
especially if you're busy it came to his
mind immediately
all of their research is publicly
available for free on their website
and more importantly givewell never
takes any fees so all of your tax
deductible donations are given to the
charity you choose
since 2010 givewell has helped more than
50 000 donors direct more than 500
million dollars
to the most effective charities these
donations will save more than 75 000
lives
and improve the lives of millions more
so if you want
to have the best bang for buck each
dollar you put in to have the greatest
impact
this is just one of the fastest easiest
ways to hone
in on the best options the highest
leverage options
this year you can support the charities
that save and improve lives most
with givewell if you want your donation
to have even more impact
you can act soon any of my listeners
that's you guys
who become new give well donors will
have their first donation matched up to
250 dollars when you go to givewell.org
tim and select podcast and tim ferriss
at checkout
this matching offer is good for as long
as the funds last
could go quickly so check it out this is
a special chance for even a small
donation to make a big impact
get your first donation matched up to
250 dollars
when you go to givewell.org
tim and select podcast and tim ferriss
at checkout one more time
definitely check it out givewell.org
tim
this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to total
you can dial weights up and down with
the touch of a button in one pound
increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting a tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
the four hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout on tonal focusing on
pulling
i was blasted for a full week it's
really incredible what you can do
with eccentrics they also have all sorts
of other
really really cool advantages that you
can apply to any of your favorite
movements tonal learns from your
strength and provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try tonal the world's smartest home
gym
i'm going to use mine today i am looking
forward to some chop and lift
tonal's strongest deal this season is
happening right now
visit www.tonaltonal.com for 250
off of your tonal purchase that's one
more time t-o-n-a-l
dot com this exclusive deal is only
available for a very limited
time so today is the day to grab a tonal
one more time t-o-n-a-l dot com
tonal be your strongest
at this altitude i can run flat
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
jim welcome back to the show it is such
a pleasure to have you again
it is really a joy to be back with you
and
for all of those people who may not have
heard the first session we did together
we did such a marvelous job of
extracting
my particular approaches to
self-management
that i hope some people will go back and
find that previous one
and then we can build upon it from here
and in the spirit of conversation you
and i love conversation we love ideas
i'd love to begin with maybe turning the
tables a little
just asking you some questions and i i
was
rereading the four hour work week and
and just kind of getting myself into
your head
about what you wrote that about 15 years
ago was that right
approximately yeah yeah 2007.
yeah so about about 15 years ago about
15 years ago
so the first thing that just struck me
as i i noted in there that you had
really been affected by ed shao
and i'm curious if you're still in touch
and also
what you really learned from him
yes we're still in touch professor ed
shao spelled
z-s-c-h-a-u for people interested
he's also appeared on the podcast not
too long ago i would say
a year and a half or two years ago
and we're still in touch and ed
had a tremendous impact on me on
multiple levels and i was first exposed
to him
when i was a student in his class called
high-tech entrepreneurship ele
491 so it was a cross-disciplinary class
it spanned a few different departments
electrical engineering
operations research finance and ed
appealed to me
and i think appealed to a lot of people
because for those who don't have any
context
he is a true polymath and a very curious
character so he had been a competitive
figure skater he'd taken a few companies
public he was
one of the first computer science
instructors
at stanford and if my memory serves me
correctly he became that
because the person who had been
appointed to teach didn't show up
and he just raised his hand and so
became one of the first computer science
teachers he
was a congressman and is really the
consummate
teacher in my mind
and encourages all of his students
to do it their own way to
live life their own way to not depend on
a predetermined path and
we are still in touch we are still in
touch and i'm still in touch
with most of the most impactful
mentors from my life story and
he's getting up there in years in
chronological age
but sure strikes me as quite
intensely young and what do you think
his
arc teaches about you know really
accelerating after 60.
well i think that
not to invoke the cliche but some things
are cliches for
good reasons that youth is in the heart
or youth is in the mind i think that
ed has made a life of exposing himself
to
new ideas new technologies young blood
in the form of vibrant young
energized students
and entrepreneurs founders full of piss
and vinegar
so i think that has a an osmotic
carryover effect
into his own life which i believe he is
extremely
aware of those would be a few of the
things that come to mind he he is
constantly challenging his own
understanding of the world and
possibilities via proactively exposing
himself
to new things and new people so i i'd
love to bridge from that to a question
that's been
just really simmering in my head all
weekend
and so you have this
this wonderful course and he has this
kind of look you really don't have to
force yourself into a box of what a
whole bunch of other people want you to
do
or how you should live or how you should
you know expand your life and your
your talents there's only one uh you
better use it well it goes by really
fast
and uh if i sort of understand the story
you kind of went out and
you know hit the the soul-crushing
day-to-day experience of this thing that
you and i are both
constitutionally incapable of enjoying
called a job
and i sort of you know
there are those of us who for better or
worse we are constitutionally
unemployable
and then sort of from there to if i
understand the arc
of the four-hour work week argument it
was essentially
look if you want to have a life of
experiences and meaningful experiences
and freedom of choices and how you
live that by very creative and
disciplined approaches
you could kind of squeeze down the
amount of energy that's needed to
earn the cash flow needed to be able to
have the experiences
and a great life and that there was a
lot of both tips and
overall principles for doing that have i
got it kind of essentially right
you did i think that is essentially
right i would
i would say that creative and
disciplined could
also just as easily be replaced with
creative and
experimental i think the experimental
component is is a
large large piece of the puzzle but yes
you did you did nail the essence so so
now here's here's the question that's
been on my mind
and i'm really curious to hear how
you've evolved on this
so at that time you if i also heard it
right you didn't come from a wealthy
family did not
you had a something about your parents
combined earn something like 50 000 a
year or something
but basically came from like you know
look there's not a big safety net
it's not like hey i can just go do
anything people support it
you have the reality of the world and
and yet you weren't going to bow to the
strictures of the way
regular work would happen and so you
share a lot of your wisdom from your own
experimentation with that now what's
interesting is
that was really focused off to me
anyways as you were really focused at
that point on
i can get the work part down so i can
really do this life thing
your life's different now your life is
different
in that that question of what's my
minimum monthly cash flow i need to be
able to fund great experiences
is actually no longer a relevant
question for you
so my question for you at this stage is
what keeps tim ferriss going
what is it that drives you in your work
because the option
of just experiences
is fully available so what is it that's
changed for you
that's now the inner motor that keeps
tim
ferriss going and going that is an
excellent question i'll try to
not give a terrible answer a few things
popped to mind for me
and the first is
an appreciation for in a search for
beauty i think that the
search for beauty and elegance
which are similar in my mind but not
identical
has become the fuel for the seeker
if if that makes any sense and i
find that in my own personal experience
that when i search
for beauty which seems like it is
absurdly too high on maslow's hierarchy
of needs to be relevant to anyone
perhaps it sounds very abstract
that i tend to find more truth
than when i purely try to deduce
truth intellectually in a very
prefrontal
way and that the to use a crass term the
return on investment
of finding those examples of
beauty far surpass a lot of what i had
white-knuckled to achieve
through crunching numbers and digesting
spreadsheets
not to say there isn't a value to that i
think it is necessary but i have found
it
insufficient if you want to
experience what we might call some
semblance of of grace i know we're
getting
out into uh maybe the the deep waters
here a bit
what's an example for you of so it's
interesting actually i really resonate
with this idea
of the exquisite right
and and and the word you know that i've
often
you know when i even when i'm engaged
with
profit-making companies or whatever at
some point there's just something that's
that making something exquisite making
something
excellent because it can be
it's not a means to an end it is an end
in itself
and i always think about that wonderful
parable of the i think it was one i
learned heard from drucker actually
about
the sculptor who made these these
statues
uh that the city fathers had asked to
make these statues and the statues were
were you know to be up in the town
square and
he he made he put in all this extra
effort and took this extra time to make
the backs of the statues
as beautiful as the fronts of the
statues
and the city fathers are well
why did you do that nobody will ever see
the backs of the statues
and his answer is ah but the gods can
see it
and i know it's there right
and so and and you know that that notion
of
or making a sentence just just right or
the simple cadence of where you place a
comma right uh are the person we both
admire in writing john mcphee you know
his sense of the exquisite
single sentence i really relate to this
and i'm curious for you like what's an
example
like how wide of a range does exquisite
or beauty go for you is it exquisite
experience exquisite
painting the exquisite goosebumps of
beethoven's symphony number three
movement number two when it
goes into the funeral march i mean what
is it
it is uh all encompassing
in a sense and i i would also rewind
to a bit earlier when you asked me the
question that has been on your mind over
the weekend
and i can't remember the exact wording
but it was something like what drives
you yeah what keeps
tim ferriss going right what keeps me
going
so i think that if we look at
keeping someone going there are
different ways to keep someone going and
you can feel driven we use that word in
english a lot
i think that for some that if we were to
unpack it has some level of being
whipped forward in terms of sentiment
there is a
sometimes there's something we are
running away from as opposed to running
towards if that makes any sense there's
some type of pain or dysfunction
or wound next to our strength that is
driving us forward and then there's a
very distinct feeling which is that of
being
pulled towards something and
i have found it more sustainable
enjoyable
and ultimately more aligned in recent
years
to seek those things that pull me
forward and beauty is one of those
indicators it's kind of the light at the
lighthouse
tim o'reilly is is one of my favorite
thinkers fantastic person a technologist
a well-known publisher and he and i have
had
a number of conversations and one of his
practices at least at the time that we
were speaking last was
to take a photograph of one flower
each day and that is a practice
of recognizing beauty it's not that
beauty is hard to find it's that it is
easy to overlook
so cultivating the eye and the awareness
to spot beauty whether that's in a
flower or
quite frankly in something that would
normally
be found repulsive like decay of some
type
is endlessly interesting to me and
i do find that when i am attuned to that
the simplicity of that in the same way
that
mary oliver might simplify
the approach to prayer if
someone were to want to explore that
practice
as an example even in a very secular way
which
might sound like an oxymoron but i'll
try not to
drown us in the deep waters too much at
this point in the conversation
i do think that a lot of it is is driven
to uh or are not driven to i would say
based
in reactivating
instincts that have been
not forgotten but just in some
fashion laid dormant right so there's a
quote from dh lawrence that i like a lot
which is
it's very simple be a good animal comma
true to your instincts
that's it and i've operated very
much from a metaphorically speaking left
brain analytical perspective for
decades and i there are tremendous
benefits
and applications for that uh
and i'm trying to in recent years
pay equal attention to the millions of
years of evolution
that preceded language that
have as an end product in some fashion
a whole spectrum of what we might call
instincts that i believe to be
deeply intelligent and powerful as
as guiding forces so know i'm not sure
if that answers the question
it's very interesting and i asked the
question for for sort of two levels
about what keeps you going i mean
genuinely curious because you were at a
different stage in your life and you
wrote that and
people who still resonate with it today
very much may also be back where
you were when you were doing that you
know they're facing different
constraints in life and and wanting to
create their freedom with that and um
and and it gives them a toolkit for for
that a very useful toolkit
and one observation and then just
something
that i found for myself is how i think
about this is that
my sense in reading the four hour work
week was that it was in many ways kind
of reacting to
the order in which you were placed the
uh sort of i reject this
i'm gonna do it different right and and
and did right
and it's kind of like moving away from i
don't want that
and the way you describe it now is it's
a moving
tort that's right right
it's a moving toward beauty towards
exquisite towards
exploration as opposed to reacting from
it is very striking in the tone
difference
i i found as i've thought about this for
myself because i
i have you know like you didn't have
much of a safety net we talked about
that in our last episode
and taking big entrepreneurial or the
big bet that joanna and i took and it
was very scary and
and so forth still wanting to go forward
and do it
and have these sort of different sort of
drives early
and i've thought of it as kind of what's
the point allocation
i always tend to go to point allocations
and numbers and so forth but
what's the point allocation between dark
force motivations and light force
motivations
and dark force motivations for me have
always been the things like
anger rage channeled channeled rage
insecurity need for attention just you
know accomplishment to show
others i'm capable right those things
that i felt very much when i was young
and then there's like force
points which are i just love the work
like i just love the work or i love the
people i'm doing it with or
the sheer curiosity of the question or
i know i can make this better even if no
one else notices
so therefore i want to make it better
and the sheer joy of
seeing something come out on the page is
like wow you know that's a that's a neat
sentence or whatever
and the drive for contribution being
useful as we talked about last time
versus being successful and so forth
and so what i have found is that for me
it's trying to be you know uh moving
decreasing the points out of a hundred
that are
dark force motivations which i would say
when i was younger were
80 20. and i was afraid to let go of
those
because i felt that you know if i let go
of the
emptiness in my stomach because my dad
didn't pay attention to me you know i'll
lose my drive
right yeah lose your lose your edges
i'll lose my edge right i need that
i need that that's the fuel that's the
kindling that's the that's the explosive
power within what if i lost that
right yeah and the sense of fear that
what if that went away
and and and then gradually realizing
that
actually if i replace that with the
others right the point allocations go
from
80 20 dark force and they flip to and i
don't think i'll ever get to 100 zero i
really don't i'm too way too human for
that
but if i can get to 80 20 light force
it's constantly generating it doesn't
ever
have an end and and you can let the
others
sort of go and it is a moving toward
versus a reacting to
it's very interesting to hear that let
me just ask you
just in terms of beauty i just one other
thing and then
i'll put myself in in your hands i
uh uh you know somebody said to me are
you ever gonna do a podcast i said well
i'll sometimes you know be on one but if
i get a marvelous podcaster then i can
just
be the questioner so um so the uh
uh so anyways i think you and joanne and
i
all share something in common which is
we are all
dean fred hargett on and admits is that
right
that's right okay that's right we are
and uh we were both admitted by dean
fred at stanford you were admitted by
dean fred
at princeton and i noticed in your book
you said i'm not sure why they let me in
because like i was sort of off the
sort of normal mode like when you think
of all the you know straight a
double 1600 sat whizbrain
you could fill the whole class and still
have like 200 left over with people like
that
why'd they let me in and so i got to
share with you this story
did you ever meet dean fred i did i did
okay
so i got to share with you this story
but it ties into the idea of
creating something beautiful so for
my 25th college reunion i was asked to
go
and be on our class panel and after the
class panel
was the presentation in an interaction
with us
by dean fred who'd come back he was at
princeton then as dean of admissions but
he came back to
talk to a bunch of us who he'd admitted
we got to chatting afterwards he came in
over and found joanne and me it turns
out that he was a real fan of good to
great
and he also had a framed picture of
joanne in his
house i think at the bottom of his
stairs in her cycling outfit
from the years that she was won the
ironman her
uh back then one of her uh you know
sports endorsement
posters and so it's kind of like it was
sort of fun sort of coming full circle
that that he was still following us in
some way
but in that conversation one i asked him
how long does it take you to
make a great admissions decision he said
30 years and 30 minutes
it's just a great example of cumulative
pattern recognition right and then he
he had shared with this camp member that
was just us personally or the whole
group but
he said you know what i've really
learned is that you have to put the
extra little splash
and things that isn't just every kid
looks like every other kitty so let me
tell you the story about this
young woman who applied she came from a
school in like eastern oregon
and there were like eight kids in the
school or something and her
advocation of choice was demolition
derby
and i decided princeton needs her
right yeah so so is that great
princeton needs her so she gets to go to
princeton princeton needs her right so
when i heard your story about that i
thought you know maybe he had one of
these moments right you know this
guy's different princeton needs tim
but anyways um but but here's the the
the end of the story i was thinking
afterwards though because it really went
into my head about
creations of things and how
you know you could look at it is that
well if you're dean of admissions at
princeton
you could just take you know a whole
bunch of the kids that look the best and
throw a dart and you're going to have
a really good class you might not get
the demolition derby you might not get
the tim right but
you'd have a really good class and i
thought there's something artistic about
that
and so i i had this note to myself
send a letter to dean fred send a letter
to dean fred send a letter
and and and it was kind of sad there you
know like these things like i should get
around to doing
and so i decided to i decided to send in
this letter
in this letter i wrote a little
paragraph
that essentially says as follows and it
just gets to the notion of exquisite and
then i want to put one coda on it
some would say that the dean of
admissions at stanford and princeton
cannot fail
given that the ratio of a talented
applicant's deceits
that may be true for creating a good
class
it seems to me that a great
undergraduate class requires the hand of
a master sculptor
the details at the margins the choices
about what not to include
the stroke of genius to include
something just
off enough to be perfect like a
demolition derby
player from a small town in eastern
oregon
if each class is a work of art then you
have sculpted
a series of masterpieces and so i sent
him this letter
and shortly after this was
2008 shortly after a few months later i
got a letter back from him
and i think this is something that i'm
going to try to remember for the rest of
my life
he has a very nice letter very very
thoughtfully composed
he says this thing he says you're taking
the time to send such a thoughtful note
happens to be a perfect example of what
i had in mind of my baccalaureate
address the class of 2003
i encouraged them not to underestimate
the value of small gestures
and provided examples from my own
experience
when asked to summarize my comments in a
few words enough to be inscribed on a
carved plaque for a new
dorm classroom building dedicated last
fall as hargen on hall
i wrote quote the most treasured gifts
in the world
are kind words spontaneously tendered
and now i mean i'm sure many people
have wonderful words to him i'm not
trying to take extra credit for
words to him but what if i'd never got
around to sending
the letter
before he passed away
and i try to remember that because we
have these people in our lives
you know and in a time like this like
you know that we're living through with
the pandemic too i mean
you never know when the people you might
want to say something to
might disappear any number of things can
happen
accident disease life just expires
and i hope that i
take in this idea that if you have it to
say
don't wait too long i second that i have
been
personally too late in a number of cases
and
you know truthfully passing the
midpoint on average of
life spans on my paternal and maternal
sides
so on the on the on the male
side of the ledger if we look at the
average age of death across
both sides in my family it's 85 i turned
43
last time i had a birthday and i was
like okay i've passed the 50
points assuming that we don't have some
singularity that allows me to become a
cyborg with immortality
i've kind of passed to the outer edge
and i'm on the return path with the
boomerang
so that reminder
to me at least that stark reminder of
mortality led me
just in the last i would say three
to five years especially the last three
years to reach out to
many of my mentors who are older
and that has been what is galvanized
the rediscovery and the reaching out
that you mentioned having done yourself
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on
fifty percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you
at an incredibly low cost wealthfront
software constantly monitors your
portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess
cash to move into savings or an
investment account they've really
thought
of a ton they've checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride
let the professionals do the work for
you go to wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
so i would like to ask you because we're
talking about influences
and mentors and we're going to spend
quite a bit of time i think discussing
this
i want to discuss father figures but i
want to do it in a somewhat roundabout
fashion or an
oblique fashion and
going back to our first conversation
and i have to just as a slice of life
for people
listening tell you tell you meaning the
listeners and also you
jim why i love you so much just as one
example and i'm gonna read since you
read
a paragraph i'm gonna read a paragraph
which is from you for tim
greetings from the creative monk mode
cave this is a letter that
i'm holding in front of me that i
printed out i'm really looking forward
to our conversation i went back to the
transcript of our previous conversation
and systematically analyzed it to cull
out what we did not talk about i thought
that might help us to create a part two
conversation that is distinct from our
first
here are some topics we did not discuss
in our last conversation or that we only
briefly mentioned
there might be possibilities to consider
for this conversation most important tim
let's have fun and you provided me with
the most immaculate and
diverse and tantalizing outline a
a producer could ever want so thank you
first and foremost for that
and as as luck would have it i did a bit
of prep
myself also and what i do at the end of
my interviews
and i did this at the end of hours is i
circled certain things we didn't get to
or notes i took
with highlighter and put r2 next to them
which meant
in the case that we ever have a round
two these are some of the things i would
like to
explore and
from that first interview there's a
quote in the transcript which is of
course from spoken word so it's not
intended for publication but
here's the line and so i kind of decided
i would create my own
father by reading biographies
of people i really looked up to and so
i'm wondering
if there are any particular biographies
that have impacted or influenced you
along those lines in seeking to create
your own father by reading these
biographies
when i set out on that that was there
were sort of two parts of
creating my own father one was
biographies
and the other was mentors and
the biographies were relatively
wide-ranging and they kind of fall into
both the memoir
autobiography category and then the full
biography by someone else category
and i'm still a voracious learner from
biographies i think the arc of entire
lives is one of the
greatest sources of of wisdom
you know to really understand the arc of
a life and one of the things you find
when you do that is that
i don't care how remarkable the person
is they all have their
their mistakes their setbacks their
wandering periods their whatever and
it's
it's kind of encouraging this is going
to sound like a strange one but it had
an
utterly profound impact on how i view
the world
and that was early on one of the early
ones i read was winston churchill's 4
96 page memoirs of the second world war
and i read it you know all six volumes
including i'll still never forget you
know reading these tables you know
shipping tonnage loss north sea march
1942 i mean
you know this is really detailed stuff
but you get a map and you follow the war
but here's the thing
you're going through the second world
war in winston churchill's head
there's no kind of better way of sort of
thinking about
what coming at the world is and crisis
and
leadership and everything else than just
go through
all those years in his head and that was
one that i still
i feel that it had massive shaping uh
impact
on me and then of course the later
churchill biographies by william
manchester who i think is one of the
great biographers
the last lion series one and series two
and then of course his his own memoir
goodbye darkness
which had a real impact on me it was
where he turned his own
lens upon himself as one of the great
biographers
and he said what i'm going to do is
i'm going to unravel a mystery and that
mystery
is why i as a marine went back to my
unit in okinawa when i was already had a
million dollar wound to go home and
nearly get killed
and had this recurring nightmare of
himself arguing with a
younger self about this decision and
trying to understand it and he went back
and
wrote a memoir of his years as a young
marine a memoir himself as a middle-aged
man
going over um the same terrain
right in all the islands and then the
the story of the pacific war all wrapped
into one
and it had a huge impact on me because
it it's really ultimately about love
and you do whether one ever does
anything heroic
it's it's an act of love but not all the
biographies are ones that
sometimes what i would describe is
negative and or
just instructive so for example i think
robert carroll's work is extraordinary
i love his i mean i i relate to his
desire to spend
uh months and months just immersed in
information and detail and getting
everything and you know make sure you
read all the files and so forth i
i personally relate to that but his book
the power broker which i think you know
i think is one of the great biographies
now what's great about it
is that it it shows actually
the reverse um we were talking earlier
about uh light force dark force
i think his dark force motivations
increased over time
and that old adage you know power
corrupts
from lord acton right absolute power
corrupts absolutely and then i think the
last part of that
is uh very few great men are goodman
what cairo does so unbelievably well in
that is he takes one person and
shows that happening could you give a
little more context
on perhaps robert moses not that we have
to go too deep into it but just so
people know
who the subject is it's another one of
those things where it's it's a
it's a book that's somewhere along the
way it's really worth getting to
because if i remember it right it was
quite a number of years ago when i read
it
if i remember it right the essence of it
is you had
this person who had a really peculiar
genius and his peculiar genius was the
ability to find
sources of power to be able to get
things done
that were often unseen by other people
and he started out as somebody who in
new york
who didn't have any obvious formalized
sources of power
and he went parks originally and he
ended up
playing this massive role over the
course of his life of the shaping of new
york and it's almost impossible to look
at the way new york works without
thinking about the imprint of
robert moses upon that for for better
and worse
and how we got that done and how we got
the beaches done
when there were lots of powerful forces
allied against and his ability to
find pockets and pools of power to be
able to harness to get these things done
without any formal power to do it and
then
what caro if i recall correctly does so
so well is he shows how
it gradually grows from power to get
things done to power because you can
and he does it in 1200 pages or
something it's sort of a counter of
light it's really fascinating like you
talk about a bug book this was the
ultimate bug book on
on power and robert moses the examples
of what you don't want to be
are also important in your biographies
his biography is lyndon johnson
extraordinary
the one that just still stuns me to this
day and actually a great takeaway from
it
is uh master of the senate you can watch
cairo
start off almost like i don't like
johnson
he sort of doesn't but he grows to
appreciate his skill
and when he becomes master of the senate
his ability to get things done if
politics is the art of
possible like this was michelangelo at
work
whether you agreed or disagreed his
ability to do it
you know and again i always distrust my
own memory but
if i've got it right right at the end of
the book as he's leaving the senate to
go become
vice president carol writes something
along the lines of
he did not know it at the time
but in leaving the senate he was leaving
the only home he ever really had
at least that's the way i remember it
and
the takeaway i got from that was
never let your ambition confuse you
about what you really are so he always
wanted to be
president but what he was
made for was master of the senate and of
course as presidents he ends
doesn't seek a second term and so he
achieved his ambition
but lost his home
yeah i think that's easy to do we could
have the tim and jim
conversation for biography after
biography
well maybe that's maybe that's the easy
way for you to do a podcast you just
have
tim and jim tim and jim howard
now i know you are a fan if if i'm
getting my homework
done properly of ron chernow's biography
of george washington yes and
uh george washington is is fascinating
on so many levels you know in part
because he has this
cincinnatus like quality of being the
reluctant
ideal leader right the perfect candidate
is very seldom the one who wants to run
for office and
so i know you've publicly discussed the
impact of that biography and and you
brought it up of your own volition i was
going to
lead from that to the question of
what you can learn from not the jedi not
the white knights
of the leadership canon so to speak but
from the sith lords
those who have not to push the
sith used too far but who are
masters of power but with some shadow
elements
and i'd be very curious to know we we
spoke of
of one robert moses who also is
portrayed i think very
well in the film adaptation of
motherless brooklyn by
edward norton played by alec baldwin
robert moses was perfectly cast
what are some of the lessons that you
have been able
to retain from
some of these darker leadership
icons or icons of power
and have you been able to use or absorb
these things without
being infected by some of the other
components of their personas because
it's
strikes me as very difficult to emulate
only a tiny percentage of someone
if you're not careful at least you know
it's an interesting question because it
is interesting how i went to moses and
to the johnson biographies
the the carroll books because they
uh they really do they are
there are things there that's like i'm
not sure i would want i would want to be
and as you know i'm a big consumer of
this thing called the great courses
series where
you basically go out and they found the
best university professors
for the quality of their teaching like
i'm doing a whole course right now on
how the brain works right and and
the professor is from vanderbilt she's
wonderful just for sheer joy of like
and this is how light comes in and
actually your brain then creates an
image and isn't that wonderful just
leaves you with this incredible sense of
awe
and how everything works there was a
course on philosophy and i
i feel bad that i don't remember the
name of the professor i probably
might come to me towards the end of our
conversation but it's called i think
it's called question of value or
question of values
and in that course the professor makes
this wonderful distinction
he says you know you might want to think
about whether you want a life to envy
or a life to admire well that's great
isn't that
so you take lincoln it is not a life to
envy
you know he struggled with depression he
had a you know a
tumultuous set of relationships he had
personal tragedy in his life and then
the handy gets dealt as president to i
mean imagine sitting there getting the
battle reports from antietam i mean
and then he finally gets to it and then
he gets his life taken away i mean it's
not a life you would choose
but it's absolutely a life to admire is
it professor
patrick grimm yeah that might be it
yeah it's called question or questions
of value or value questions of value
yeah and i just and i was so struck and
i i think
what i'm really interested in is
the people who maybe ultimately
they transition they don't become one or
the other they grow
over the course of their lives and i i'm
almost more interested
in the growth cases than
in kind of the static cases and what's
fascinating with moses is he sort of
grew in
the other direction but kind of the arc
of change
of people's lives i find it really
really interesting and even
even washington's an example of that
early in washington's journal
by the way have you had chernow on i
have not
yet that'd be wonderful sure now would
be able to speak to this far better than
i could but
how early in washington's life very very
you know really
just incredibly ambitious right and he
has
some setbacks and and then you see over
the course of his life how his ambition
gets
increasingly channeled out then into the
intersection of history
and how that intersection of history
then brings further
a sense of almost historical service
out of him but the washington of his
later years is a much more evolved
washington than the washington of early
years and i think that's what's
interesting
because i think this this question of
we're not
fixed we're not static right there isn't
uh you know we may chat a little bit
later about there wasn't
steve jobs there's steve jobs 1.0 and
steve jobs 2.0 right i mean it's the
it's the arc
it's the growth that's what's
interesting to me well
let me give you just a map of the
territory actually just leading to the
horizon i like to give people an idea of
what's coming so we are going to talk
not just about books but we're going to
talk about mentors since that was
the second component that you mentioned
and
we're going to talk about bill lazier
specifically but before we get to bill
lazier
because you brought up questions of
value
i would like to ask you a question about
questions
because i think many people consider you
a
provider of answers i
would agree with that to some extent but
i view you more
as a craftsman of questions and
the description of questions of value
just as a leaping off point
is of course for anyone who has ever
felt the tug of such questions or who
wants to
fine-tune their ability to see how
deeper questions of ethics and values
apply to the choices that make up their
lives okay
so let's take that and jump to a new
york times piece
about you which was published in 2009
and i'm going to read
this paragraph mr collins also is quite
practiced at saying no
requests porn every week for him to give
speeches to corporations and trade
associations
it could be a bustling sideline given
that he commands a top tier fee of 65
000 to dispense his wisdom side note
from tim
i would say at this point in time i
wouldn't be surprised if it were twice
that amount
back to the new york times paragraph but
he will give only 18 speeches this year
and about a third of them will be pro
bono for non-profit groups companies
also ask him to consult
but he mostly declines agreeing only if
a company intrigues him and if its
executives come to boulder to meet him
over two half-day sessions for sixty
thousand dollars he will ask
pointed questions and provide very few
answers
quote i am completely socratic he said
and i challenge and push they come up
with their own answers i couldn't come
up with people's answers
book tours no splurging with the
millions he's earned from his books no
too the part that i underlined was the
over two half day sessions
he will ask pointed questions and
provide very few answers
what types of questions or could you
give any examples
of questions that you have found over
the years of
experimentation and refinement to really
more than pull their weight and as a
side note i will say i know some people
who have flown out with their leadership
teams to meet with you
and two three years later they're still
talking
about some of these conversations so
could you give any examples of questions
that you like to use
yeah so um so first of all i
i'm so pleased that
you see me as more about the questions
than about the answers and
and and i i really
i am genuinely just deeply thrive on
questions and
and it's that's why i think i again so
they go back to that course
i didn't really take away like these are
the answers on
value like i took away a question let me
just describe a little bit
how i prepare for
really anything but particularly prepare
for a socratic
lab and first of all it starts with
probably something very similar to what
you do because you're socratic
is you kind of have this big funnel of
trying to gain understanding before you
even
enter a conversation you read you learn
you try to get your thoughts around what
are the really critical things
and then the next thing is to start
asking the question
what are the questions and
if you can identify the questions and i
think of the questions
i think of it this way i think of it as
like preparing
for if i were an nfl coach
and you are going to go into the game
with a game plan you've prepared really
well you're going in with a game plan
and when you get the ball you're going
to know your first few plays in all
likelihood unless something weird
happened early
and so i'll come in with some questions
that i know
a little bit like green bay packers
always had their first set of
plays and you always knew what they were
then the game would unfold
and so you have to be really clear what
are the two or three really essential
things that
they don't walk away having wrestled
with this i have failed them
not these are the things i need to tell
them these are the three things they
gotta really wrestle with
and your task is to get to those
now you walk in but then it's like the
game starts
and what you have to do is okay we
weren't we were planning on
you know throwing long on third down but
their defense isn't allowing for that
they're
leaving the whole middle open so we're
going to run drop plays right
and so you prepare obsessively but then
you have your questions or your place
and so i have opening questions and the
first one is always the same for
inside organization one at least
historically has been i you know
it's not a core value this could change
but it works like this
he's got a picture everybody's in the
room they've done homework ahead of time
they've had to answer a bunch of
questions ahead of time which i've
digested all their answers i walk into
the room i'm in that room right now it
was set up in covid time to use that
room as kind of our
our little studio here the table we had
custom made
just for this room it's a totally secure
room
there's no if you look at the four walls
on either side there's no way
that information could escape into the
outside world but for some people
we've had people send security sweeps
and things like that i mean it's very
important that things remain
in some cases very confidential and then
the session started at 8 am
now there's a rule with that 8 am
doesn't mean 8 am and 4 seconds
8 am is 8 0 0 000 because you have to
set the tone
bang where we are going to engage here
now people have often wondered why do i
require people to come to boulder
very simple it's not because i don't
like to travel although i don't
it's when you're dealing with people who
can buy
anything and you want to have an impact
on them
with the limited number of chances that
you know maybe they'll only be able to
come once
or you might only have them come once
what's the one thing they can't get more
of their time time
so by requiring that they all have to
come here and they're in this space
in these rules i've set the conditions
for full commitment
right so those people still talking
about it years later it isn't just
because i ask good questions it's in
part because the conditions were created
of
you have to make a commitment to come
you have to make a commitment to be
really present when it happens i
wait until exactly eight o'clock
and on day one i walk in the room at
eight
zero zero zero and i go to
my chair and i say
good morning take out a blank sheet of
paper
it's not like how was your flight you
know how you know what do you think of
boulder hope you had a good meal last
night good morning
take out a blank sheet of paper we have
i feel tremendous responsibility
we have a lot to do write down
the top five brutal facts
that you face today
okay we are now at eight o'clock and
what 12 seconds
and there quiet blank sheet of paper
brutal facts right out of the front and
one one thing that i have found
is that if you start there and then
that's the very beginning they go sheet
of paper brutal facts
then we have six corners in the room six
cornered room
and there's a random process by which
then they're put into small
and then they have to come back to the
large table and i'll randomly pick
someone and i say okay
what are the top five brutal facts that
you face and then each of those becomes
something to start pulling on
why is that a brutal fact is that really
a fact there's a rule
no opinions allowed facts only you can't
say i think we're growing too fast
that's an opinion facts facts facts
and if you begin right at the start
the conversation gets very rich very
quickly
because everybody knows what those facts
are
but you put them on the table that
quickly you are already setting the
conditions for tremendous momentum
at the setting of conditions yep it's
how underestimated
yeah and then from there you have a
number of them we do a lot with you know
sometimes it's the flywheel sometimes
it's the hedgehog
almost always something on people uh and
what makes for the right people
there's almost always something on
danger signs i
really like to ask people to take the
five stages of decline from how the
mighty fall
and self-diagnose where where are we
vulnerable here
and why and what would we need to be
worried about and those sorts of things
and
zooming out 20 years and those types of
things but
once you get into it then there's no
script that is the same for everyone at
that point it's all
very conditional upon who they are but
it's always going back to the principles
from our research
well people go to boulder
to learn to be interrogated
and challenged i think challenged
challenged let's introduce bill lazier
who is bill azir why is he worth having
a conversation about
so the spark for us doing this
again is i'm re-releasing this my very
very first book
which is called beyond entrepreneurship
bringing it out is beyond
entrepreneurship
2.0 with some upgraded material and new
chapters and so forth but
a big part of the reason is because i
wanted to honor and extend the legacy
of my co-author on that book bill lizier
and first sort of how that intersects
bill passed away in 2004 and when i was
in the memorial service i think there
was about a thousand people there but i
just had this overwhelming
need to write something about bill
and i thought i could write an obit i
could write an article
i could write something for the alumni
group
and then joanne as is often the case in
my life
had this really great idea
she said why don't you create something
permanent
which would be to take this book that
was your first book
that you and bill did together and bring
it back to the world
but really shining a light on bill and
what he did to change
your life and the role he played and
what a great mentor is all about
and then it's by bill and jim
and it brings him out permanently and i
can share him with the world
and so that's kind of the impetus of all
of this
and just something that was very
meaningful to me
i got my first copies so last week was
either the last week of the week before
copy001 uh went to bill's widow dorothy
and uh i started like no matter whatever
happens from here like
that's it everything else from here is
gravy
so bill why why why was he yeah why was
he such
an important or perhaps arguably the
greatest mentor he was greatest mentor
in my life
i think the best way is to just tell a
story
we talked earlier about this notion of
dark force and light force motivations
and so forth and
i met bill when i was
i think i was just on the verge of
turning 25
and it was complete luck and the last
episode you and i did together we talked
about who luck a lot the whole log of
peter drucker the whole luck of
four days to a to marriage with joanne
to
engagement with joanne and here we are
40 years later and so forth
but this was like luck in a real sense
i'd wanted to be in a different section
of a course
and it so happened that i didn't get
into that one and i got assigned to a
different course and there was an
unknown first time teacher of that
course named lazier
and i said anybody know anything about
this this guy was here nobody knew and
so i just went
and i figured i would just find find out
what he was like or what the course is
about
and that sort of chance interaction
led to bill somehow taking an interest
in me and the image i have is that
i had that i was like this propulsion
machine this this
driven creative energetic
propulsion machine but but i had nowhere
to no
direction to it if you will and
and bill took this interest in me and he
started inviting joanna me over
to his house now he'd been a very
successful he was an accountant
then a very successful entrepreneur and
in his 50s
he returned to stanford to really begin
teaching kind of a renewal phase in his
life
and i became like this project for him
and he just kept working on me just just
he would ask questions and he would be
and he he was never judgmental he was
just believing and supportive but the
key was he believed in me
he just believed in me and then when i
was
30 just i think i just turned 30 hours
there about
there was this moment when all of a
sudden kind of like the ed show story
you were describing earlier where there
was this
unexpected vacancy in the
entrepreneurship and small business
course
at the stanford business school bill
taught one of the other sections
which was the course i had taken from
him years before
and the deans needed somebody to
fill in for this other professor who was
a star professor
and bill went to the deans and suggested
me
and then put himself on the line i mean
put his
sense of his own reputation on the line
he said i'll try to make sure he doesn't
mess up too badly
and because of the clock i think more
than anything else
the deans let this happen
and then bill essentially
kind of got me to see that this
it's like that's like that thing in
hamilton you know don't throw away your
shot
this is a shot and
the idea of being the image i've always
had in my head is
imagine you're a pitcher way down in the
minor leagues and you happen to be in
yankee stadium and for whatever reason
all the pitchers
on the bus don't make it to yankee
stadium and the game's about to start
and somebody says why don't you go out
there somebody's got to pitch you just
grab a glove go out there and pitch
and bill's message was there come these
times in life well not all time in life
is equal
and the quality of your performance in
that moment
will have outsized effect on the rest of
your life
if you throw a perfect game you'll get
to throw again
a go throw and that was the start
of everything and had had i not had
bill's class
had i not had bill believing in me and
then from there
till the end of his life shaping me
guiding me
challenging me modeling for me you and i
wouldn't be having this conversation
the degree wouldn't exist built to last
wouldn't exist how the mighty fall
wouldn't exist beyond entrepreneurship
wouldn't exist
great by choice wouldn't none of that
would have happened
i have some thoughts about what i might
have ended up doing but
this is a whole lot better and that was
bill
and it was his caring and investment
this is what i think made him such a
great mentor
he so believed in me
that it created a sense of
responsibility to him
to that standard you don't want to you
don't want to
fail that you don't want to let that
down
that it acted like a magnet and it just
pulled me
up what are some of the life lessons
that you
gained from bill and that have remained
highly important to you
so i put some of these in in the book in
the notes
yeah and in the book yeah exactly
because i got this whole chapter on sort
of the lessons i want to share with the
world from bill
and i could pick any number of them
maybe we'll pick one or two is there
anything
i can pick one yeah just because i'd
love some some clarity on it so
i'll i'll give people just a teaser of a
few never stifle generous simples
great life comma great relationships
trust wager which is the one
i would love to hear you expand on
values is the hard stuff
and then put the butter on your waffles
which i also love
but maybe you could expand on just since
i'm following my own curiosity here
trust wager yeah and then and then maybe
a little bit on butter and the waffles
because i think it's something that
you may relate to but the uh
even though i think you're probably more
fanatic about diet than i am but anyways
i'm more fanatical about consuming
copious amounts of butter than just
about anything so
okay this is in my strike zone yeah so
so the trust wager after i had
left stanford and in the previous
episode uh we talked about that
what joanne and i called our thelma
louise moment of launching out over the
chasm and
betting on my own entrepreneurial path
uh to try to be an entrepreneurial
professor rather than a professor of
entrepreneurship
and when i left the
very protective walls of where i was
i started hitting other sorts of
experiences including
and i won't go into specifically who and
what they were but situations where
people i trusted had abused my trust and
it really stung i hadn't
really experienced that in life before
and just realizing you know not
not everybody is trustworthy and some
people are really
not trustworthy and so i went to bill
and i said bill have people ever abused
your trust and how do you deal with this
and he said yeah they have but
this is one of the big decisions you
have to make in life
you have to decide as a basic stance
are you is your opening basic assumption
about people
that they are trustworthy
you always start there your opening bid
is trust and trusting them always
and they can lose that trust if there's
incontrovertible evidence
that they have abused your trust but you
always have to be clear
never attribute to malice what could
simply be explained by incompetence
and the other path is to
start with you have to earn my trust
i'm not necessarily going to trust you
but through evidence and experience
you'll earn your trust he said this is
one of those big choices in life it's
just a basic stance
what is your stance and i said well you
seem to trust people
he said yes that's my bid i said well
but but how do you deal with the fact
that people are not always trustworthy
he said well well so long as you don't
leave yourself
open to catastrophic loss and it was
always very clear
always pay attention to the cash flow
and he described a situation where he'd
lost
enough money from somebody he trusted
that it hurt right didn't crush him but
it hurt
and he said but i still come back to i
would rather live with that
i said well help me understand though
the the pain you have to deal with that
and and the fact that people are not
always trustworthy
he said look jim think of it as upside
and downside
here's the wager now what's the upside
if you to taking the bid of mistrust
well you'll maybe prevent
yourself from having one of those
hurtful experiences
and what's the downside the downside is
trustworthy people
you will lose them and the upside to
trusting people is when you find the
trustworthy people
they will rise to it and if and he said
this was the critical thing he said to
me said have you ever considered the
possibility jim
that not everybody is one or the other
but because
you trust them at the outset
they are more likely to become
trustworthy because you trust them
and ever since then that i try to live
to that the idea that that's the opening
bid
and just make sure you protect your
flanks so it can't be catastrophic
but that was bill hard-headed realistic
but you always start with the opening
bid of trust were there any
footnotes on that trust and i i guess
i would love an example of what trust
means in this context if that if that
makes sense because um
you know the expression that comes to
mind is trust but verify right
so if i get an email that says i am the
the widow of a nigerian prince and can
you please
wire 10 million dollars to this
following bank account and i
here's how we'll split the 100 million
proceeds i assume that he does not mean
you wire the 10 million
in a circumstance like that right that
would be an extreme example
but you much like and we may get to this
a bit later also but you know i've read
of
how you think about luck is asymmetric
as a causal force right so bad luck can
kill you but good luck cannot make you
great
it may be necessary in some
circumstances but not sufficient
similarly
there are certain downsides that are
survivable
there are certain downside risks that
are easily
manageable and then there are sort of
existential
or catastrophic downside risks so
how did he trust from an informed
or a smart place as opposed to a
reckless place does that make sense
well when it came to business dealings
bill
always i guess i did sort of describe it
and if i understand this one situation
that he referred to
he always had a good awareness of the
cash flow
in his environment like he used to he
was just fanatic about always understand
your cash flow
very practical person on that i remember
one day he was teaching a class
on uh it was for the entrepreneurship
and small business and he was pushing
the students on what are the really key
issues in the case and they're all going
off about you know our strategic
positioning and you know where uh
yeah sort of market share growth and
whatever and finally bill just sort of
walks over to the white board and puts
in
about four foot high letters
with the side of the chalk all the way
across the board
one giant word cash
and and he's
and and and he he always tried
particularly for people who come from
earnings world you don't pay your bills
with earnings i mean you pay your bills
with cash
and so bill's practice always was
to be very aware of where the flanks
were and to ensure that
he would never leave himself exposed to
say having something where he would wake
up and find
that you know something had been taken
that left you completely crushed if you
will
completely embezzled or anything like
that right just where the cash flow
but when you bring somebody in do you
not trust that they're going to do a
great job do you not trust that they're
going to
uh steward the resources of the company
as if they owned it
or are you going to basically trust that
they will
he basically would always just start
with i trust you
i trust you and the idea of like locking
a supply cabinet or anything like that
just
i trust you you could lose that trust
but it's just know where the flanks are
and we'll probably get to that when we
get to the luck part because i think
that has a lot to do with this sort of
notion of
managing what's catastrophic versus
managing what's not
and in the end here's the key thing bill
was
all about relationships and bill
believed
that the only way to have a great life
is two approaches to life to seek
transactions
and see life as a series of transactions
or to take life as building
relationships
and the only way to have a great life in
bill's view
was relationships and the cornerstone of
relationships
is trust and then you can put butter on
your waffles together
presumably okay so let's talk about
butter on the waffles because
i've been thinking about eating waffles
ever since you mentioned it yeah so
but this okay so butter on the waffles
is something that this is still
something i really struggle with but i
learned from bill
we were working on beyond
entrepreneurship i didn't know what i
was doing as a writer and i'm sure back
when you were
writing your first book there's this
incredible sense of inadequacy
right does that ever go away
what i've actually learned is that
writing is like
running if you're going to run your best
let's say you can run a six minute mile
and then
now you're a better runner and you can
run a five minute mile if you're gonna
run your best whatever your pr
is it is always going to hurt
writing never gets easier
you only get better
so i was going through but i was
i don't know i was running maybe nine
minute miles i was throwing all kinds of
stuff in the waste basket i felt
completely overwhelmed there was
i truly felt inadequate and i was
suffering and so i go to bill
and we're working on this together and
i'm doing most of the trying to get the
text
working and i sit down with bill and you
can tell i'm just sort of
really suffering and and i described to
him how i
i'd spent the entire day the day before
and it's all in the wastebasket
wine wine wine and i expected bill to
give me
this maybe this lecture on you know this
is the time to push through and
you know you have to sometimes you have
to double down it's like the last six
miles of the marathon you're only at
halfway at mile 20 in the last six or
where everything happens and that's when
you really have to grid it out and
that's what i expected to hear and
instead what i got was a lecture on fun
and bill says to me he says okay
so if you're not having fun and we're
not having fun doing this
we should just stop and he said if we
can't find a way to make
this fun we shouldn't be doing this
so the day after we turned in the
manuscript
bill had a heart attack and he had a
quintuple bypass surgery
and we used to have these waffle fests
at the peninsula creamery
and we would we would meet there on
saturday mornings and we would have
waffles and
a few weeks or months i can't remember
the exact time length
we're having one of our waffle fasts
after bill
had had his heart attack we sit down and
just like before he
pulls out all this butter and starts
putting butter on his waffles
and putting syrup all over the the
butter and creating you know that
marvelous mixture
of like syrup and butter creating that
marvelous
mixture of of yum stuff on your waffles
i said bill bill what are you doing you
had a quintuple bypass surgery you were
putting all this butter on your waffles
and bill just continued to pour the
butter on his waffles
and then he looked up at me and he had
this
most marvelous expression it's like that
it was sort of a smile but it was this
it's hard to explain what it is it
reminds me of that line and
seneca's right on the shortness of life
you know there's a wise
as a wise person who knows how to meet
death with a firm step
and and bill told me this story
of going into the operating room he said
i bet they saw a smile on my face
because i'm going into the operating
room and i all the sudden knew
i mean i knew without question
that if this was the end i'm okay with
that
dorothy and i have had a great run
i have lived my life the way i wanted to
live it
i have so many people in my life who i
have loved and i love
i have already had a great life
and nothing can take that away
and so i decided coming out of it
everything from here is
gravy and i'm going to leave my life and
i'm putting the butter on my waffles
bill never confused a long life with a
great life
and he died a number of years after that
not that many years
after that maybe a decade must have been
maybe 12 years later
he woke up and was walking across the
room and he
fell dead of congestive heart failure
and dorothy later told me that he had a
smile on his face
and when i was in
the stamford chapel i saw all these
people
in there i cried
and it was such a different crying
because when my dad died
i cried for what i never had
when bill died i cried for
what i had lost
and then i look out in that stanford
chapel
and i see all these
people in there and i realize i'm not
the only person
whose life he had altered
or hundreds of them and i had this image
of them as like vectors going out in
time and space
and that if you can affect the
trajectory of a vector
even a few degrees when they're
relatively young is a huge sweep
as their life unfolds and imagine you
did that for
not just one vector not just one jim
collins but a whole bunch of other
people
and you have hundreds of those vectors
going out into time and space
then you've lived a really great life
and you had butter on your waffles
and so you know it's interesting you
notice i put here most important tim
let's have fun
on my memo to you um i am really
trying this is for me the hardest of the
lessons i learned from bill
just putting a premium
on if it's you can't find a way to make
it fun you shouldn't do it
let's see it seems like bill was not
only having fun
he fulfilled
and you know fun at least temporarily
can be bought with a bottle of wine
but you know fulfillment not
quite as transactionally available and
i'm going to jump around here just a
little bit but this is the
next topic that popped to mind for me
which is related to this
and that's contrasting your time with
west point cadets having spent time
at the united states military academy at
west point
with your time with mba students at
stanford
because it seems that the cadets
seemed happier and
i would like to know in your mind why
you think that is
yeah maybe perhaps what you know to be
true about
what what separates those two groups
because
you you i think in the minds of many are
a
uh you are a researcher and a student
of success uh but you and i can both
point out examples of people who are
extolled
uh or put on a pedestal as these
pinnacles of success and yet they have
these peric victories
they they go home they have terrible
relationships with their kids with their
spouses etc
so this is deeply interesting to me the
contrast
cadets versus mba students so back in
2012 and 2013 i had this real honor to
serve a two-year appointment as the
class of 1951
chair for the study of leadership at the
united states military academy at west
point
and first of all just personally it was
a
incredible experience to go and
be invited in and especially in a
special role like that
to really get a feel for how does a
place like west point one of the great
leadership development institutions
in the world probably in history do its
thing
with young people who come in and what's
their approach to things and had a
profound impact
on me in many ways and i went there
theoretically to teach something to the
cadets but really i ended up
as is often the case being the student
and i used to have these marvelous
dinners
where i had this big round table and i
would invite about 12 cadets and
just start off with a simple question
beginning to ask them questions about
their lives but
how did you end up here where did you
grow up why did you choose this versus
something else right
and just getting to know each cadet and
why they would choose this path
marvelous journey well anyways the more
i got to know the cadets
and the more i engaged with them the
more i was struck
at by and large how happy they seemed
now you gotta try to understand what
life as a west point cadet
is like i didn't go to west point i i
went and studied
math on the west coast they have not
just
their hefty academic load we've got you
know history and philosophy and
engineering and all of these things
you also have your leadership training
you have your physical training you have
your military training
right and you don't have a whole lot of
free time this is an intense place
and i'm finding myself thinking what is
it and there's this sense of them being
on the balls of their feet and this
sense of
you know energy and and i'll i'll never
forget when i had the
the joy that's the only word i can use
the sheer joy of being able to close out
my session with the west point cadets
with a
one-hour presentation to 5 000 cadets
all in their camos in eisenhower hall
for an hour and at the end of it the
eruption the the
roar from them that just sort of
conveyed the sense of sharing
joy if you will i was like wow this is
really an interesting place the
energy wow if you could just bottle that
what is that how does that happen
what's working here and so i
puzzled a lot because what's really
struck me
is they did seem happier if i could i
can't measure that i can't prove that
they're happier but they sure
felt happier to me than my stamford
students when i taught in the business
school
and so i i came away with
a couple of key thoughts on maybe three
that go together
the first begins with i'll just have to
lead into with a little bit of a story
i always like to do something physically
demanding or
challenging in some form for my fives
so for my 55th birthday which was when i
was there
i decided that i wanted to do this thing
called the ioct
the indoor obstacle course test because
i kept asking the kid apps what's hard
about being here they kept talking about
this thing called the ioct
i said well what's the ioct sir you
don't want to know we all
we all hate the ioct well what is it
it's the indoor obstacle course test and
it's this
place called haze gym and the idea being
that you you know you have to
leap over things and mantle up on a
shelf and go across these sideways bars
and
cross a balance beam and over walls and
you know hand over hand across bars and
then up a rope and then
run around the track with medicine ball
but here's the key there's a graduation
time
you actually have to hit a time and
i said well i think i'm going to try to
do the ioct and 22 year old cadet
graduation time as a 55 year old and
i was having trouble with this because
it was actually quite hard it's not a
good idea by the way
and i was over there training and uh um
and and you know the cadets were
wonderful because they'd be coming along
they said sir don't do it like that you
look like an old man sir i'm like well i
am an old man so anyways i'm working on
the ioct
and i'm training and one day and all of
a sudden i stand back and i look around
and i noticed something there are groups
of cadets
who are clearly not having any trouble
accomplishing the ioct
they'll hit their time easy who are in
there
taking out time out of a life where they
don't have extra time
to help their classmates
who are struggling with the ioct to
ensure that they get through
and all of a sudden it just parted for
me realize
what's happening here is the entire
culture is built on the idea that you
are not alone
and that your response to this sucks is
how can i help you and the idea being
that you
the thing you have to learn is we will
take care of each other
and i began to think about this notion
of
success is communal it's never alone
it's never solo
and there are people there that are
going to help you and then your
responsibility is to help someone else
if you have trouble
with the ioct and somebody helps you but
you might be good at math and you're
going to help them
and that was very different than what i
saw
in other environments so very different
from what i see often in corporate
america
and if you could grab that idea
that you are never alone and your first
responsibility is to help someone else
versus advance yourself and you make
that systemic
built-in cultural
the other part is the ethic of service
and we talk a lot about service and
kids should do things for services
there's another thing when
every kid that's there knows
that either they
or somebody close to them or somebody in
their unit
may well die in the rendering of that
service
and that creates a context of meaning
that is i think very hard to find other
places so you have
the service which you are in service to
what you are willing to sacrifice for
what you might even die for
and those around you
and take care of each other and the acts
of love
that is i think a very special and very
powerful concoction
and i think it explains a lot of why at
least i don't know if it was happier
more meaningful
more but it was this extra x factor that
is palpable so i want to make a
a military leap to
and and i am making a bit of a
guess but i i think i'm i think i'm i
may be right here so
after 30 years of work in research you
have a single map
of concepts and a framework now and if
you die tomorrow that is what you would
want
people to have and follow
one of the bullets in this consolidated
map of concepts
is the stockdale paradox
is this stockdale the pow
yeah or is this a different stockdale
could you we don't have to necessarily
start with stockdel but because
you mentioned seneca earlier my stoic
reading and leanings i'm fascinated by
by stockdale so let's approach this any
way you like we could dive into
stockdale paradox or
we could begin just by taking a step
back and looking at the macro of
of what is meant by having a single map
of concepts
after 30 years of work and research so
here's what i'd love to do
with that tim is i actually would love
to pick up on
just the previous part of our
conversation and go into stockdale it's
one of the
key principles in the map and i feel in
today's world by the time people hear
this
we're really in a stocktail moment and
so i would love
for people to hear from me the stocktale
paradox if that's all right with you it
involves
the story yeah so for people who don't
know admiral jim stockdale was the
highest-ranking naval officer military
officer and the hanoi hilton prisoner of
war camp
and in north vietnam he was shot down in
the late 1960s
and he spent seven years in the camp
and i had the great privilege to be able
to get to
know admiral stocktale a bit when he was
studying stoic philosophy
across the street at the hoover
institute when i was teaching my
small business and entrepreneurship
class over at the stanford business
school
and in preparation for this walk across
campus and lunch that we were going to
have i sat down and read his book
in love and war which is written in
alternating chapters by himself and his
wife
about his years in the camp
and now i want you to picture i'm
sitting there in a really nicely paneled
warm stamford faculty office looking out
at the fog
kind of coming in over the hills and
it's this beautiful setting and i'm
and you know i'm comfortable i'm safe
i'm reading a book
and i found myself starting to feel the
sense of despair and feeling
depression because as i read the book
i really began to realize
the bleakness of a situation but what
really struck me about it is not only
could they
pull him out and torture him at any time
and they did that they could keep him in
leg irons
uh for extended periods of time and they
did right what really struck me was the
sense of he had no idea when
or how it would end so
it's not like you walk into the hanoi
hilton and they give you a slip of paper
and say is your release date is december
31 1972.
you have no idea you don't know how long
you'll be there
you don't know uh what it's going to be
like all the way through it
you don't know if you'll reunite with
your family again uh
there's no sense of when this might come
to an end
or if it will come to an end and it was
that never-ending sense this just
oppres that struck me as that was hard
and then i dawned on me i'm feeling this
reading pages in a book and i know the
end of the story
i know he gets out i know he reunites
with his family
i know we're gonna go for a really nice
walk on this beautiful campus
in just a few days how on earth did he
live it not
knowing the end of the story
how did he not capitulate to despair
so i asked him and he said ah i never
never capitulated to despair
because i never ever wavered in my faith
not only that i would get out but i
would
turn it into the defining event of my
life
that in retrospect i would not
trade
so we didn't say anything for a while we
just walked
he was very comfortable with silence and
we walked and we walked
finally i said admiral stockdale who
didn't make it out as strong as you
oh that's easy it was the optimus
i'm kind of confused here and he said oh
by optimus
i mean those who said we're going to be
out by christmas
and christmas would come and it would go
we're going to be out by
by easter and it's going to come and it
would go and we're going to be out by
christmas and it would come and it would
go
and they suffered from a broken heart
and this is when i learned from admiral
stockdale
this idea you must never ever confuse
the need on the one hand for
unwavering faith that you can and you
will prevail in the end
with at the same time and at the same
time the discipline to confront
the most brutal facts as they
actually are today i always have this
image of admiral stocktale saying we're
not going to be out of here by christmas
deal with it
years later i was working on the
research for what became good to great
and i kept noticing those level five
leaders we talked about in the last
episode they haven't had leader
companies through
often maybe years of
desperate experiences to get to the
other side
and they all seem to have that strange
duality this sort of unwavering faith
they would get there in this
incredible stoicism to confront the
brutal facts
and one day i shared the stockdale story
with the research team and
everybody jumped in saying essentially
that's it it's
that's exactly what we're seeing with
these people
and we ended up calling it the stockdale
paradox
i find whether it's this covetime people
hopefully may be listening to this after
covet time because i certainly
anticipate there will be one but
we go through stockdale moments whether
it be like we're doing on a global basis
right now we are in a stockdale moment
companies and leaders and entrepreneurs
go through stockdale moments
times in our lives that you go through
stockdale moments remember last time we
talked about
the spreadsheet i keep where i do the
plus one plus two zero minus one minus
two
calculation of the days and how you get
a minus two day you can feel like you're
in a really dark hole
like everything is colored by that well
part of coming up with that is the idea
to basically lend faith that when you
look at the data
you see a lot of ones and twos that you
can't see clearly when you're in the
minus two
was a sort of an actualization of living
the stock to a paradox you've got to
confront the fact today sucked
or this is hard or i am feeling really
down
or whatever and this unwavering faith
that the plus twos will return
may i ask you a question about your
scoring book yeah your spreadsheet
because i don't think i asked this last
time and that is
uh well as a lead-in there are
there are many different ways to get to
the same average
and one approach let's just say
and i'm not saying this is the objective
but your goal were to
hit a certain average one way to get
there would be to have
consistently plus 1 negative 1 plus 1
negative 1 0 0 plus 1 negative 1 another
way to get there
would be plus 2 negative 2 plus 2
negative 2 0 and so on which of those
do you prefer if either
more or less more or less volatility
if you choose less volatility you're
getting lower amplitude on the positive
days
yeah oh that's a that's a great question
uh let me think about that for a minute
because you know i find they come in
strings
okay so so there's a couple things i've
observed just so for those who
didn't hear that episode the essence of
it is i i i score this i
track two numbers every day i track the
number of creative hours i got for the
day and they have to sum up over 365 day
period
i always have to be above a thousand
creative hours and my
my self-imposed march is that it has to
be above a thousand creative hours
every 365 days every day of the year for
50 years right so that's that's the
march on the creative side
um then there's this other part which is
tracking how does the day feel
was it a plus two day plus one zero
minus one minus two and the reason that
that's very important to put in at the
end of the day is
the next day you might feel different so
you've got to put it down that day and
then start looking for correlations
about what correlates with twos and ones
and minuses and so forth and i do this
every single day and but as i begin to
go back and look at patterns i find i
find a couple of things the first is
sometimes there are strings you might go
through two three weeks
that are you know a lot of plus one plus
twos and the averages are starting to be
above one which is really good
by the way to be above one means there's
twos and ones and not a lot of negatives
and then you might get a string of you
know a week that's just
you know for whatever reason and often
it's just you wake up in the morning and
you have that sense of dread and anxiety
and you can't shake it and it sort of
colors everything
i've learned how to deal with it by
basically preparing for the things in
the future
but you begin to see those and you begin
to see that they come in strings
and so what do i prefer i just prefer a
lot of ones and twos accepting the
brutal fact that there are minus ones
and minus twos
but in terms of the amplitude so the
reality of life is
not a lot of plus twos and not a ton of
minus twos
uh which is why the average is sort of a
little more consistent
but i really love the plus twos and so
if you gave me a choice would i rather
have
minus twos and plus twos well that's
really hard to answer
um that's really hard to answer you know
one thing i have
noticed though this is just myself i
mean i'm i'm my own
weird idiosyncratic case so in studying
myself
one of the things i've noticed is and
this is part of what
is great about life and self-observation
i can find that i can have minus twos
and plus twos right next to each other
it is astounding sometimes there's
strings right but some sometimes it's
just astounding how
you can go have one day where you're
just like man if my life was going to be
all these minus twos it's just not a
life i want
and then the very next day something
changes and it's a plus two and you try
to figure out what that is
i can't always explain it but it's
incredible and it's that notion also
sometimes i've even noticed that
something starts off feeling like it's
going to be a minus two
and you observe that like man it's going
to be a minus two day
no the day's not done the day's not
written the day is not
over i have choices i can make
so can i turn this what's looking like a
minus two day
into at least a plus one or plus two the
day is not
written and i found that you can begin
to start
changing them i think that i've learned
some of the triggers that caused the
negatives
i think comparison one of my one of my
mentors michael ray
had a wonderful line which is comparison
as the primary sin of modern life
and i find that any time i find myself
in comparison as opposed to others
as opposed to hey am i making backs of
the statues as beautiful as i can
that tends to correlate with minus twos
uh much more so
i find that if um
uh i'm also very sensitive to how other
people around me are feeling
and if other people are having minus
twos i might be more likely to have a
minus two if you don't want me digging
into the comparison because i think this
a lot of people will
resonate with comparison
if not as the primary sin of modern life
as that was michael's
statement there's a good one right right
as a predictor
or a harbinger of negative two days um
how did that well let me let me ask you
first i mean the question that i have is
would you be willing to give some
examples of how that shows up for you
how are you comparing yourself to other
people because you strike me as such a
uh such a unique snowflake
uh i don't know who you would compare
yourself to exactly
i mean i'm sure we can always find
people maybe it's some incredible you
know
514 rock climber i don't know but how
how did how does it most often show up
for you
comparison this seduction this kind of
moth to the flame of comparison
and how did it show up for michael ray
if you have any idea yeah well michael
michael ray is uh was a very evolved
specimen and the way i mean he was a
academic professor professor of
marketing then taught the creativity in
business class
and i think that in you know the world
of
academia with peer review and with
kind of the tenure ladder and all of
that it kind of breeds a sense of
comparison and
and i think that totally yeah and you
know and where your office is and a
whole bunch of other things in a way
it's kind of a com
and then silicon valley i mean if there
is sin city
it's silicon valley in terms of
comparison is the primary sin of modern
life
right and and so uh and michael dealt
with it by
very very deep spiritual practice uh
that that was the way he
he dealt with it uh what was his
spiritual practice he just
he did he was involved uh very deeply in
a very extensive
meditation and uh studying under uh
i believe maybe more than one guru and
he
he dedicated his life to his own
evolution
to find what he always described as to
get in touch with his you know real
inner essence as opposed to his external
forms
and his life was very guided in that
direction
i think that you know for me sometimes
it's changed over the years i think when
i was younger you know
it was would be you know sort of more
surface level comparisons it's never
been like gee how am i comparing
financially or how am i comparing just
my i actually would rather
compare with uh people being you know
maybe surprised uh
say oh you don't have x and y and z i
kind of like that you don't have windows
in your office like
i kind of like those sorts of
comparisons of being like different
but the yeah why don't you have the
corner office with all the windows
exactly because there'll be windows
it'll be distracting
we were talking earlier in our earlier
one about john mcphee you're like can
you can read a john mcphee paragraph and
go
i don't know if i could ever do that
paragraph
that's a really optimistic stance i just
said god damn i can't even imagine
ever producing a parody exactly exactly
you know but it's it's it's sort of
i think sometimes it's it's just these
standards
that and then i see people who embody
them and you feel
whoa inadequate to those
and that's where some of the comparison
comes in
in climbing it's great as you get to be
62 or 63
you know you're gonna lose a comparison
with anybody who's 25
so right right not on the table
yeah what do you do if michael ray had
his spiritual practice
to act as a countervailing force a
counterbalance
to the very human i should say instinct
reflex evolutionary pre-programmed
tendency
to compare what do you what do you have
what is your what is your pattern
interrupt
or sort of method for mitigating the
tailspin or possibility of
that negative two due to comparison yeah
i've learned some very specific things
that again
i'm idiosyncratic to myself everybody
probably has to find their own patterns
and i certainly
am not one to prescribe that other
people although after our last session i
guess a bunch of people started
spreadsheets and good i hope they're
helpful to them but
people have to sort of find their own
recipe and that's what the bug book's
about right
to begin to observe for yourself as you
study yourself like a bug
what really works and for me i've
learned a couple of things that that
the critical thing is to find something
very tangible
that pivots me to the future and what's
coming next
and and so for example i've learned that
if i wake up at
four or five in the morning and i know
i'm hitting the 20-minute rule and i'm
not going to get back to sleep
and i can feel those you know what is
the 20-minute rule
minute rule basically says if you wake
up in the middle of the night and you're
not back to sleep by
20 minutes you get up and get going
and uh and so i i followed the 20-minute
rule and i hit the 20-minute rule like
there's no way i'm getting back to sleep
so
get up and keep going but in that 20
minute you can there's something weird
about laying there in bed in the
darkness that you can it's almost like
feeling the
you can feel those it's like a black
mist sort of coming in and you can begin
to
all of a sudden you're thinking about
something that's whether it's comparison
or comparison to something you to
a standard you could have done better or
whatever here's what i've learned
just even this last weekend as i was
preparing for our conversation
i have found that one of the best things
to do
is to throw myself into creative
preparation for something that's coming
up
and to go into the preparation bubble
and the reason for that is simple
there's nothing to compare to at all
there's nothing to
be like judgmental of there's nothing
none of those things
they've never they haven't happened yet
right they're all in the future
and all your energy goes from you know
looking backward or looking to the side
or any of that and and all that just all
of a sudden becomes this energy and roll
out of bed go
right right to the desk and then
immediately pop up and say what have i
got coming up i need to prepare for
so hey i'm going to be talking with tim
i better be thinking about what did we
talk about last time what could be
different this time like what maybe
i should probably go back and revisit
the the four-hour workweek and all of a
sudden this generation of i'm preparing
i'm preparing i'm looking forward i'm on
the balls of my feet
i'm creating right it all goes away
and so uh and i have a little thing on
my
on my iphone which is i have my to-do's
like everybody else and
i also have my stop dues on mine but
there's
i have a thing called prep and prep is
always in bold
and so whenever i'm in that point i
immediately go to the bold line that's
called
prep and i say what can i prepare for
and then or or i can be preparing for
you know that also applies if i go into
my research but again
that's for ideas that have yet to happen
i can't judge the ideas
they're not there yet what do you use to
to contain your to-do's stop do's and
prep do you use notes
do you use a different application where
do those things live
i am a and the people in our little
system here
know this i'm a fanatic for simplicity
i'm not always so good at it but uh i'm
a fanatic for simplicity
i don't like really complicated i'm
sorry
to app makers and all that i apologize
to you so how do i keep my
my to-do's i use the notes app
on my iphone and which also that carries
over to my ipad
and i have two two versions of it
there's the
beginning of every year you sit down and
you do your sets of threes
right top three things to get done this
year write them down
top three things to stop doing or reduce
significantly this year it has to
balance
three for three if you have more than
three in your top set you don't have any
priorities
then right truly and then and then you
go down to
top three what i call supporting
objectives
so for example um you know i might have
a top objective
redesign the socratic process i might
have a supporting objective which is
uh create a new table for the space
right something that's supportive but
again only three and they're supporting
the big ones but they have to be in
support of
and then um and then there'll be other
threes like you know
uh i actually have one top three fun
right i'm
really trying on that right that's this
is still one of the hard ones for me
so you do that and so i have those over
there on on one thing and you go back
and you constantly and at the end of the
year you grade yourself
right and you don't grade yourself you
don't get to change it you have to grade
yourself at the end
on every one of those at the end of the
year a b c
d f you can use minuses and pluses if
you want
and you grade yourself relative to
exactly what you said
you were going to focus on for the year
now something may happen you might get
sick or
and have to deal with that or whatever
but you grade yourself and you go to
that
and it's on a simple note it's just a
simple like little memo pad right and
then
you have your what's sort of going on
which is the long list every time you
think of something you need to do you
just add it to it's a memo note
that's all it is but the critical step
and you wrote about this
you're really good at this tim when you
sit down
you do the very thing that you wrote
about i think in the four hour work week
and i found it very very helpful
sit down and you just look at that list
and you say
okay what are those two maybe three
things today
that like and if only and maybe even one
of them
right this is today and sometimes
it can be simply as today is a day that
if i didn't have fun
it's a failure right because it's going
to be a fun day or whatever but then
here's the
little trick i've learned there's all
the other to-do's and they might go on
for
hundreds of things just so some day you
don't always forget about them
i'd like to hit return enough times
that when you open the memo which you
always have keys so it can open up
instantaneously when you open the memo
all the ones below those top three are
off the screen
and they're there right but
they're purposely hidden and it's simple
it's just simple and i use for date
things i use the thing on the iphone
which is jus uh
the you know their simple reminders
thing but like around here we could have
all these you know we could have like
all these powerful apps for tracking
contacts and stuff like that
i'm like you know or things that we have
to prepare for i'm like
why don't we just use an excel
spreadsheet or
a word document i just think
the critical thing is if you don't have
the discipline
no app is going to make you disciplined
speaking of discipline what are some
examples of things on your stop
do list well i think one of the biggest
ones on my stop do list and i give
myself
so far used to be always my grades are
rising
one is don't hit send
what does that mean so uh you know one
of the things i learned from
another wonderful mentor fellow named
irv grosbeck
you can always say something you haven't
said
you can never unsay something you've
said
and so i it's very simple thing but i
never draft
an email response in an email app
i never draft an important text in the
text app
because you might hit send and sometimes
it's a matter of when you hit send
so you'll i thought about the shock it
hits my system if i'm up at four in the
morning
and something occurs to me and i text
and email
people on my team at four in the morning
first of all they don't need to know
about it at four in the morning
at eight i might not even think it's
that important because it just was
according to me at four in the morning
and uh and i've shocked their life this
is
completely unhelpful so i
put it in i don't put it in the map i
just type it out
and i would say about somewhere between
a half and two-thirds of my
correspondence i never send
wow that's amazing partly because
i like a conversation if i can have that
and one thing i've really observed with
really effective people i'll never
forget
every once in a while in a couple of the
conversations that well i've actually
had this with multiple people really
remarkable people
i've noticed that they often see the
purpose of email is to
is to trigger a conversation
by voice dear jim can we chat
how do you feel about that about oh
about dear jim can we chat
uh yeah well i'm reclusive
so often that's but if it's if it's the
right person i mean there are things
that can happen in
a you know by voice and conversation
that can never happen
imagine having this conversation by
email
right harder
it'd be really it'd be really really
hard to do so another thing is i i have
uh travel is at least on uh it's clearly
right now i would have stopped doing but
i ideally would love it to be almost
permanently a stop doing travel for
other than
fun and those are some that are really
you know i'm still very much working on
but the when in doubt don't hit send
if we return to the consolidated map of
concepts
this uh this map of concepts and
framework after
30 years there are many that we could
talk about and
you can feel free to to go off menu with
what i'm going to mention
but i would love to hear more about the
genius of the
end or clock building not
time telling okay great but you can you
can choose option c
if there's another one you think would
be more more fun to explore
right let me zoom out for a moment about
this map
and then i'll i'll pop into a couple of
comments about that so first of all
what is the map starting way back when i
first started teaching
the entrepreneurship and small business
class and interest just as an aside by
the way a lot of people
think that my work has been about big
companies because the companies that
were in the research
were huge companies by the time we
picked them up to study them and
that's where the data was because they
were publicly traded companies so that's
that's
but but we always studied them back to
when they were startups so i was
interested in disney when disney was
doing a first cartoon i was interested
in you know how amgen
went from a startup into finally
stumbling upon what would become
epo i was interested in intel when it
had three people and southwest airlines
when it had three airplanes and
for me i've always had my main
interest and passion has been ultimately
for the entrepreneur
and the entrepreneur who i would like to
challenge with the beyond
part of the entrepreneurship part which
is to basically take the idea of
okay now that you have a successful
business can you make the journey from
there to build
turn it into a truly enduring great
company i mean if you're going to do it
why don't you try to create one of the
companies that
can last that's worthy of lasting that
can change the world that can go on
and continue to do that for generations
and can serve as a role model for others
like
if you can do that why don't you do that
right or at least why don't you think
about doing that that was always sort of
the frame
you get companies when they're young and
when they're small because it's like
getting them when they're really really
still in the early parenting stage and
it's
easier to turn a small business or an
entrepreneurial company
into a great company than it is to try
to change
a giant mediocrity down the road
into a great company so get it right
early that's
kind of where all this work began and i
started thinking about
how would we do that and that's what led
to the research and last one we talked
about the research about the comparative
analysis and
historical analysis and all the things
that we do that go back to
how i learned how to do this research
with jerry porus and we applied it first
and built to last
it wasn't about big it was about how the
small became the lasting and visionary
and the others did not
and each study was
i kind of think of it as it wasn't a
series of four books it wasn't like
built to last and then go to grade and
then have a mighty fall and then great
by choice
it was actually one giant study that
came out in installments
and each study was
looking at the question of what it takes
to build
a truly great company superior results
distinctive impact lasting endurance
a truly great company and after 30 years
i thought to myself now that i'm moving
on to new questions
right so after we after this
conversation tim i'm going to be heading
off and do
you know the next time we talk hopefully
i'll be emerging from the cave with
perspectives on these new questions
a midpoint of my career at 62 as i think
of it
moving on to new stuff i wanted to
consolidate
all of our work into something that
could fit on a single whiteboard
30 years of research on a single
whiteboard
and so i thought i'm going to give
people a map if you did 30 years of
research
rigorously figuring out what makes great
companies tick
and you wanted to hand it to an
entrepreneur and say follow this
here's here's the map what would it look
like
hence the map and then and then beyond
entrepreneurship 2.0 i've
written a whole chapter on what the map
is consolidates all that work
it unfolds in these stages of stage
one's about disciplined people so your
level five leaders your right people on
the bus
all those and stage two is about
discipline thought the genius of the and
the stockdale paradox which we talked
about earlier the hedgehog
concept which we talked about in the
previous session together
stage three is all about disciplined
action which begins with the flywheel
which we spent a lot of time on the last
episode on
and then uh executing on the flywheel
with a fanatic 20 mile march
minus my thousand creative hours but
companies can have them too
and then renewing and extending that
flywheel with firing bullets then
cannonballs
to get calibration and then placing very
calibrated big bets that extend that
flywheel
leading to stage four which is building
greatness to last which is
productive paranoia you've got to stay
alive and stay out of the stages of
decline
shift from being a time teller to a
clock builder because if you're just a
time
teller everything falls apart when you
go away so you got to build a clock
and then finally the real deep secret of
preserve the core stimulate progress
allowing you to achieve b hag after b
hack after b hack
those are all the inputs for people who
don't know
being big hairy audacious goals big
hairy audacious goals
and it's funny there's a long story
about how that came about
we eventually embraced the big and the
hairy and the audacious
it's a way to stimulate progress and
great companies in history
many of them have used b hags very
artfully to stimulate progress
and then there's finally in the map one
principle
that multiplies all the others which is
the principle of return
on luck and that was the
piece of analysis that morton hanson and
i did that i'm very very proud of
because we're able to define and
quantify
the variable of luck and then to ask
rigorously systematically
what role does it play what role does it
not play
and how should you think about it when
you really look at the long course of
things
you add all those principles up they can
fit on a single whiteboard they're the
inputs they follow
unfold in those sequence and i would
want if i disappear tomorrow
i would love to be able to say to
anybody who's started a company or a
business say i wanted to be a great
company
take the map follow the map i'm gone
but the map is here and that's that's
what that's all about
in terms of the genius at the end
one of the things we found is that
those who really build enduring great
companies
it may be great companies even that just
for a period of time but
get these extraordinary things going
they reject the tyranny of the ore and
they
embrace the genius of the end and so
that we found this
real ability to live with both sides of
anne's all the time when somebody says
creativity or discipline they say and
innovation or execution they say and
they say values or results they say and
and one of the big ones
is purpose and profit and we live in
this time when everybody's
it's like we've discovered purpose again
as if this is a new
discovery but jerry and i found in our
research 25 years ago
one of the main findings built to last
was that the visionary companies
have always been more driven by purpose
than their mediocre also rants in our
comparative analysis
and they were more successful
as businesses so this notion of purpose
over profits isn't quite right could you
give an example of
a paragon in your mind a company that
really exemplifies
that combination well i think one that
people would maybe
really identify with uh is uh patagonia
and yvonne chenard so people would know
it but the great
story of how yvonne chenard
grew up in rock climbing and
mountaineering
and he had this
belief that a company
should be a tool for changing people's
behavior
that would have a positive impact and i
remember back in 1972-ish
i got the china catalogue and it was a
manifesto for
clean climbing and back then we used to
bash pitons into the rock
and yvonne comes along and says you know
if we keep bashing pitons into the rock
as more and more people climb
we're going to just leave these ugly
scars and he had a picture in there if i
remember right
of a thing called serenity crack in
yosemite which basically used to be this
beautiful thin
seam that was just marred and mangled
with piton holes and yvonne
said this is wrong but then
so his purpose was he was going to
change the climbing community
to be that role model and tool for
social change which is really kind of
the purpose right
change the climbing community make it
more sustainable of what we were doing
and he was going to issue a manifesto to
that effect and the catalog was a
manifesto
i still haven't i still have that
manifesto catalog no kidding yep
and then he put that out of the world to
educate us about what we were doing
trying to get us to change your behavior
you got to remember when a piton feels
really secure
and he's saying take this little tiny
piece of aluminum that i've attached to
this webbing and slide it in and it's
dead and you're thinking man i don't
want to hit a ledge it's like no we have
to do this
these will be safe let me show you he
then provided the solution
and basically said i'm going to give you
the answers i'm going to give you the
eccentrics and the stoppers and all the
products that we could use and trust
and then made that said don't buy the
old products buy these new ones because
they will be better
and essentially led us through with his
company as the catalyst for doing it
into a revolution with other climbers
who are
calling for this too but he provided
this great solution
to be a role model for and a tool for
social change
in the climbing community which then
later has become larger for them in the
way that they do all of the things that
they do
and the power of it is patagonia is an
incredibly successful business
and it is purpose all the way along and
profit and this goes back
decades and is alive today and christine
mcdivitt who built the company with him
that was the whole thing we have to do
the and we have to do the and
we have to do the and i am so glad you
brought up
patagonia i have traveled
with yvonne chennard's book let my
people go surfing
since it was initially published i've
had a copy of that book that has
traveled with me for
however long it's been 20 years 20 plus
years
and they just do a phenomenal job i
actually have
literally a spanish paprika mackerel
from patagonia provisions in front of me
and i've become fascinated with the work
that they're doing from my
sort of biological ecological
perspective on
sustainability sustainable agriculture
and utilizing what we might consider
bait
utilizing what we might consider you
know the precursors of food like seeds
in a really thoughtful and uh
intelligent way which
exemplifies the end like you said oh
and what i think is really the thing i
would really emphasize
is there's nothing trendy about this
so jerry and i found way back and built
to last going way back to companies some
of them founded back in the 1800s
that this notion of we have a reason for
existence
that is not defined in terms of
maximizing
wealth for the owners and
we have incredible discipline to be an
incredibly profitable successful growing
sustainable business
and that we found that in our research
and then you see a company like
patagonia
you there's nothing about it that is
new there's new ways of doing it but
it's been there since the beginning
and this idea that somehow companies
should go out and like you don't bolt on
a purpose you don't say
you know i read we should have a purpose
so i guess let's go get one
it doesn't work like that it's it has to
be this inner
purpose that you have always had
and it is it's far better to
never say you have a purpose if you
don't
uh than to inauthentically proclaim one
so i i still have 7 000 pages of notes
and prompts and questions that we
we could spend another seven hours on i
think we we should probably
bring round two to a close and put a
bow on it in about say 15 to 20 minutes
sure
what would you what do you think would
be fun
or important or fun and important
to cover i mean i have questions about
of course the clock building not time
telling i have
questions about other mentors of yours
like i i don't know if this is a single
named person like madonna
i'm probably missing i want rochelle you
know if you had 10 years to live what
would you stop
doing there's so many things that we
could talk about what would you like to
talk about
or what do you think would make sense
yeah it was funny tim i uh
i was really a little bit worried and
hesitant about
doing another conversation with you
because you did such a great job last
time and we covered so much material i
thought
we're gonna have nothing to talk about
surprise
so as i if i think about
might be really fun and or maybe useful
to people but fun maybe if you and i
have fun that's where we'll have the
best use of our time here
let me ask you what would you what would
you go to for
fun i have a couple of thoughts well i'm
being pulled to
uh particularly given some experiences
in the last few weeks
is a tremendous pull
towards simplification and
i think that is why the thought exercise
of asking the question if you had 10
years to live what would you stop doing
is pulling my eye my eye keeps getting
pulled to that
maybe that's my version of fun i'm not
sure if and you're also curious about
the clock building and time telling
and i am yeah yeah so i think we could
easily do both of those if you
if you'd like um let's do it yeah let's
tackle it
so we talked earlier about you've got
the map you know the stages and then you
get to the
fourth stage about building greatness to
last and
in that is one of a key idea that again
it was
jerry porus and myself together working
on what became built to last where this
idea came out
and so first of all this kind of picture
that there's a town square and there's
this there's this amazing time teller
right that could come in at any time of
day or night and look up at the stars
and the moon and the sky and go
tell you exactly what time it is they
could tell you it's 12
13 and and 22 seconds
in the morning on such and such a date
and their incredible time teller and
you don't need a clock because you got
the time teller and one day that
i until it goes away time teller dies or
the time teller
uh you know it's decides to move to
another town or whatever now so no one
knows what time it is
and what we found is when we go back to
the early stages now this is very much
about the entrepreneurial side of things
go back to the very early stages of
companies that became the enduring great
companies so
disney is an entrepreneur david packard
is an entrepreneur
tom watson senior as an entrepreneur
george rathman is an entrepreneur
herb kelleher is an entrepreneur right
uh you go back to
we could just go through the long list
of them r.w johnson uh jay willard
marriott uh
paul galvin they were all entrepreneurs
right at some point
what happens well at some point they
they very early in their journey or
relatively early in the journey they
said
i don't want to be a time teller on
that everything depends upon me to tell
the time i don't want to be that
visionary founder uh that everything
depends upon me
i want to build a clock i could tell the
time even if i'm not here
and i'm going to start the process of
thinking about that relatively early
um whether that be the there's a whole
bunch of different things that one could
put
in the clock but i think that it was a
temperament that they had
that they understood that they had to
make a shift away from doing more time
telling
and most entrepreneurs are good time
tellers right
they they recognize it's time for x
but to shift to building a company means
i've got to become the clock builder
i've gotta you know that involves all
the things we write about about you know
picking your people
and building your systems and nurturing
your culture and and building great
mechanisms and a whole bunch of other
things like that but you
build the clock and sometimes that can
be
it's better to start clock building when
it's relatively early
anne baker who's just one of the great
leaders i've gotten to know at telecare
when she took over her father's company
he had died of an
adverse medical event and she also had
the company on her shoulders
one of the first things she did was to
sit down and say
what are the basic things we're going to
build this on so that instead of
really relying upon my father anymore to
be here
we as a company can carry on what he was
all about and that means i have to
really build the clock and of course
that's when the company really began
to take off and for the next 30 years
has been an incredible run
so i encourage all entrepreneurs now
there's one thing i want to highlight
here
there's this maybe it's not as much of a
myth today i don't know you would know
better than i do
but there's this myth that there are
these things called entrepreneurs
that have kind of an entrepreneurial
temperament
and they're really good for starting
companies
and they're really good at like you know
they're kind of these great necessarily
even crazy people they can be very
disciplined people but
they are the starters and their natural
temperament is that they should be
starting things
and then you have a different
temperament almost like a different
species
which are those who build the company
and at some times for some of these
entrepreneurs and some of you might be
listening to this right now
people around you like you're bored or
folks around you say you know it's kind
of the company's outgrowing you
it's now time for you to sort of think
about maybe you should really hand this
off to somebody who could take it to a
different
level and i encourage in the strongest
possible terms
that any entrepreneur that faces that
conversation
to look in the mirror and ask yourself
the question what choice do i want to
make
because what you find in the research is
that almost
all of the great entrepreneurs we
studied
became the great builders of their
companies
disney built disney david packard and
bill hewlett built hp
jeff bezos his building um amazon
bill gates built microsoft right
they the the entrepreneur becomes the
builder
the average tenure and harness
of the founding shapers of the companies
that became the great companies
is about 36 years
wow now you might choose that you just
want to go start something else
that's fine but don't ever let anybody
tell you
you can't choose to be the other
so um rochelle
yeah who is rachelle i gotta share with
you this
story and this image of rochelle i met
rochelle
in 1982 and michael ray's we talked
about him earlier
michael ray's course on creativity and
business
and she co-taught the course with him
now you gotta imagine you could meet
somebody that is a
cross between socrates and yoda
handsome good looking and rochelle
rochelle was just
she was just this really wise and she
was all of about five foot
and so we all come into the class the
first day we're sitting there and we're
buzzing after the
summer and what we did or whatever and
there was this five foot tall
very serene looking woman in this kind
of flowing mumu
thing standing in front of the class she
just stood there and just waited for us
to
quiet down and eventually we sort of
realized we should be quiet and all of a
sudden rochelle says
this very quiet voice
you are about to embark
on a 10-week journey to discover
your deepest inner essence
at which point i began thinking about
what corporate finance class i could
take instead
so i'm thinking man i don't know about
this you remember i'm a math guy i
love stats i love quantifying things all
this stuff
so i go home and joanne says to me so
you know how how are your classes and
i'll talk about this one jim van horn's
finance class and whatever
i said but i had this other thing i
think i'm going to drop it i told her
this story and
joanne looks at me and she says oh this
would be really good for you
so i stayed in the class and rachelle
became one of the great guides
in my life and she's the one who i think
taught me about questions
because i used to go and meet with
rochelle
and she would she would sit and she
would always begin
with the same question every time
she has a little whiteboard and she
would write on the whiteboard
the date and she would say it is
november
23rd 2020.
what would you like to get clear about
today
and then she would through a series of
questions you realize
that she wasn't really you'd come in
with you'd ask her a question
you know to try to get clear on but what
she was trying to do is to get you get
clear on you
who you are what you are what's inside
you
not like what you should do for a job
choice right
and and she
she just knew how to ask the right
questions right that was the power
the power of her questions are is her
last name myers
myers myers michelle myers
and at one point she gave me
a question which was
i can't remember whether it's five years
or ten i think
10 is a little more useful of the number
but it could work with five
essentially along the lines of if you
woke up tomorrow morning
and you discovered absolutely
you have only 10 years to live
what would you stop doing first say i
went oh i wrote down the
quit my job i was this is before i was
teaching at stanford i was like i don't
want to do this
you know this i'm not cut out to be in a
regular job
and what rochelle
taught me with that question is someday
that ten years or five years is going to
be true
you just don't know when i might already
be in the ten
hopefully not i'm hoping i'm midway in
my career but
you never know and she says you'd be
asking yourself
all the time hey
if you knew you only had ten years or
you knew you only had five years
now what would you do
first what would you stop doing
and i started using that as like a
little
guidance mechanism she was also the one
that taught me about like bug books and
stuff like that
and you just start going through every
day like if i had 10 years would i do
this
i had five years would i do this
because the truth is it's all short
that's one of the lessons of bill's life
right
it's short it goes by in a vanish
any sense of historical perspective and
it accelerates
and i used to walk into my class at
stanford influenced by
rochelle to my students and one day i
would walk in i would just say everybody
took out a blank sheet of paper
and i said i want you to write down what
would you do what would you stop doing
if you discovered you only have a short
time to live
so everybody's writing their notes down
and this you know before i went to the
numbers board
i love the numbers board but this was
one day before the numbers worked
and then um i didn't comment on it other
than just say one thing before we went
into the numbers board i said oh
and now for all of us that's true we all
have only a short time to live
do you personally still revisit that
question or do you feel like you are
already you've already called the herd
of activities to the point where you're
doing exactly what you would like to be
doing
are there things that would still be on
your stop doing list
if you went through that exercise i
continue to
i'm pretty sure that my theme i usually
do a theme
for every year at the top of that list
of the threes of you know three
primaries three stop doings etc
i'm pretty sure i set for the theme for
this year because it comes back
periodically
you know only ten years to live
and and i try to go back to because the
truth is you get pulled in lots
of different directions i can say with
complete equanimity
tim that if i knew i only had 10 years
to live
we would be having this conversation
you know i don't know i think when you
start getting into one to two years
things change because you gotta tie a
lot of
life but if you can basically get to the
end of every week and say if i had ten
years to live
it's still pretty good choices in my
life my my life is composed of things
there's not a lot on the stop doing list
there are some things that you can't
stop doing
because it's reality flossing flossing
but flossing is better if you have a
really really good course on how the
brain works to watch
that's true in fact i was interested
but i was standing there flossing while
watching this course on how the brain
works and i couldn't help myself
thinking
i wonder what my brain is doing with
this
uh yeah that's it's a it's a really
really valuable prompt and i think
kovid has has really brought that to the
fore
the fragility the fragility and
impermanence
of of life and i've had some people
close to me i've had relatives close
immediate relatives of
my girlfriend pass from code related
complications
it's been a good reminder to
revisit mortality or at least the
awareness that time is limited
and i too would be having this
conversation
and you alluded to a question
very early on that i like to ask which
was on my list of
unasked for round two which was the
billboard
and so here we go metaphorically
speaking you have
a billboard to get a message a quote a
question
anything you like to billions of people
let's just assume they all are able to
speak the same language and understand
the same language
what might you put on that billboard
doesn't have to be one thing but what
might you put on it
how have you changed the lives of others
and i come back to bill
you know we could talk about all of his
accomplishments and his board seats and
how he became a chair professor at the
law school and
he was the first ever holder of the
charles and
nancy munger um chair for
study of business and law at stanford
law school an incredibly accomplished
career
but what what is really great about bill
is he changed the lives of others
and i think that's a really good measure
it doesn't have to be a lot of people
it doesn't have to be that you change
millions of lives i don't i don't think
of it that was at scale
building change a lot of lives but
you know are some people's lives
that are indifferent because you are
here i think that
is an excellent question
to let linger to end on i think that is
an excellent place to
to stop uh jim people can find you jim
collins.com the new book which i
encourage people to check out
is beyond entrepreneurship 2.0 subtitle
turning your business into an enduring
great company
which certainly expands upon a lot of
things
that that we've discussed i find you
always to be
a a skilled and enjoyable
conversational tennis partner
or dance partner jazz improv
it's always so much fun and uh is there
anything else that you would like to
say suggest request put out into the
ether
for listeners anything at all that you'd
like to share before we
come to a close right um i'm just
looking here at our
our list and i just am so tickled uh at
how
we did have a lot beyond part one to
converse about and i was i mean i truly
was worried it was like
uh is like what are we going to talk
about that was so rich last time
we have enough left in front of me to do
round three easily
but though so i uh no i think uh
as always we we went through in a
it seems securities but actually there's
the the linear line has been the
curiosity in the in the
uh and the conversation and i love that
there are some questions where
i'm not i still want to think about my
answers i'm not 100
like which do i prefer that's a great
question actually i'm going to be
observing my
my spreadsheet to say which do i prefer
i just prefer a lot of plus twos i would
really like that
and uh and i you know once i
for me i guess here's what i would leave
uh for people is if i have a hope for
all of you
for a lot of you sure i hope some of you
start and build great companies and
that's a great use of a life i think
it's a very noble thing to build a great
company i think it's as noble as
anything else you can do in
life if it really contributes and adds
not only economic wealth but you know it
changes people's lives and
provides a great place for people and so
forth i think that is noble
um i hope some of you will take up on
doing that
but whatever you do in your life
if i could wish something for all of you
it's that you would find people like
rochelle myers
bill lazier peter trucker jim stockdale
ed chao you know the people
who can shape you and when you find
those mentors
make good on it and and then do it for
others but
i i feel such deep deep gratitude
for what they have done for me and i
truly wish
everybody got the benefit of that
abundance
and generosity that a great mentor does
for you it would be very impoverished to
not have that
and the mentors are out there they are
constitutionally
predisposed to look for that energetic
exchange or the circulating of the gift
if that makes any sense
exactly right i mean they are they are
hardwired just
just as as any any other organism might
be for something
to serve that
incredible function of mentor so they
are out there
they are out there but make sure that if
you
have the privilege of having a great
mentor it's a relationship it's not a
transaction
they're not there to open doors or any
of that
they're there to mentor yeah
and show up at eight o'clock not eight
o'clock in four seconds
so jim one one last cliffhanger request
if you would indulge me
and we can keep this short i know you
don't yet have
answers to share but
can you share the next big question that
you're working on
yeah boy um
so yeah
let me let me i'm really puzzling how i
want to share it exactly
i don't know the answers i'm about five
years into the research
and the signature of it will be the
research and
i because that's all i have to offer
ultimately is is something that's
research based if i do it right
john gardner one of my another one of my
mentors i didn't get to spend enough
time with him but
you know he had this he's the one that
had this marvelous belief
that well not not to try to be
interesting
should seek to be interested and
john wrote a marvelous book in 1962 by
the title of self-renewal
and i went down the hall to john and i
said i'd like to do research on this
because john believed one of the
greatest costs to the world is the
failure to self-renew
the failure of nations to self-renew the
failure of society's
failure of organizations and
institutions and companies
and ultimately the failure of
individuals to self-renew
and i said i wanted to do research on it
and he kindly gave me
a lot of time i saw of all my notes from
that
but he suggested i uh wait
because it will take decades to do my
great company's work that's probably not
old enough to understand it
and so i waited and about five years ago
i started a project
and i finally figured out how to do it
and it asks a very simple question
which is what's going to ultimately be
the map i just it's going to take a long
time to get to what the map is
but what is the map to self-renewal and
not as episodes
but over the arc of an entire life
and uh and why do some people remain so
spectacularly renewed
over the long course of a life maybe in
others
might not and um and what are the real
ingredients in that
and and i'm taking a very research-based
approach to it um
i can't share what the method is it's
kind of like the coke recipe but
but it's really so it's the most
exciting stuff i've worked on in a
really really long time
i will share with you one question
though and i'll leave all of your
listeners with this question because i
do know one question
it's like so far i have questions more
than answered i know one of the
questions
one of the key questions about renewal
is is ultimately going to be
are you going to be the kind of person
who renews within a primary form
a primary art form in your life
whether that be business or writing or
music or
theater or whatever it is that is your
art form
politics right or are you going to be
somebody that is going to renew
as your primary mechanism all the course
of the life by changing your art forms
so if you take john mcphee he's just
heard that wonderful interview with him
i think was on npr called the old man
project
you know and he's in this race to get as
many of his ideas out as he can he's as
renewed as ever
right but he is renewal within a single
art form
and it's a spectacular path of renewal
that started early and ran forever
but you could take other people who
renew
by changing their art forms sometimes
because it's imposed upon them you know
katherine graham one of the great heroes
in my mind
uh she she was not didn't want to what
being a ceo wasn't her art form but
because of the way
post unfolded and the suicide of her
husband she had it on her shoulders and
she chose to renew
into a different art form to become a
great ceo
and uh and i think one of the great
questions all of us have to wrestle with
because we're different
you know different bugs if you will but
one of the great
wisdom questions is to remain renewed
over the entire arc of a life i mean
like until till you're like out and done
is it going to be are you going to be
variations on a theme
or are you going to be different themes
and that is one of the crux questions
i will have answers for how you think
about that i don't know yet
and i can't wait i have to go on the
cape once i get be 2.0 out so i can help
bill
come to the world i'm going to be in the
cave
think of me happily without windows
figuring this out
so how's that for a question i love that
question i love that question
variations on the theme or different
games altogether it makes me think of
being mario andretti and lane shifting
or being a shape-shifter yeah exactly
yeah
exactly and and it's one of the wisdom
questions because it's not like there's
not like there's smart answers to this
they're wise answers and uh
and i am trying down when i really want
to understand
and this is the beauty of the of looking
over the entire
arc of people's lives done in a
rigorously selected set to try to unpack
this
and it is the most fun
and interesting engaging and exhausting
piece of research i've been in for a
long long time
i really really hope i if i have only 10
years i hope i can get it done
and i really hope i have enough time to
get it
well you know if the power broker can
get written
lyndon johnson volumes can be compiled
i have great confidence in you and
uh jim this is always so much fun
perhaps we'll have around
three at some point we certainly have no
lack well and by then
i might have something on renewal to say
so but anyways i'm just looking at the
notes here and it says most important
tim
let's have fun have we accomplished said
goal
yes yes at least i can speak for myself
absolutely me too
and what a joy to be able to spend time
together again
i really appreciate you making the time
and
i i really look forward to seeing what
beyond entrepreneurship 2.0 does
in the world and the extension
of your mentor's legacy
and to to see the ripple effects that
that will have as it's transmitted in
written form
to probably millions more by extension
uh and congratulations
thank you that's very exciting it's
about in the end it's about
bill so that's what i am very excited
about i appreciate you helping me bring
bill
to the world so tim you uh go and put
some butter on something
um
i will do the same that is that is on my
my top three to do's for 2021 is put
butter on everything the theme
the theme is fun yeah it's self-renewal
all right jim well thank you so much for
for spending so much time today and
for everyone listening as usual you can
find links to everything
that has been mentioned from the old man
project
which was dropped as a gem at the end a
little easter egg
to the new book to everything in between
in the show notes at tim.log forward
slash podcast just search jim collins
and it will pop right up and until next
time
until next time my friend take care get
some butter on some waffles
all right thanks for listening hey guys
this is tim again just a few more things
before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up i hope you
enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bank and buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to total by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal
you can dial weights up and down with
the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm
still getting a tonal installed i've
used tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
before our body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert lead workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features to
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try tonal the world's smartest home
gym
i'm going to use mine today i am looking
forward to some chop and lift
tonal's strongest deal this season is
happening right now
visit www.tonaltonal.com for
250 off of your tonal purchase that's
one more time
t-o-n-a-l dot com this exclusive deal
is only available for a very limited
time so
today is the day to grab a total one
more time
t-o-n-a-l dot com total
be your strongest this episode is
brought to you by givewell.org
tis the season of giving isn't it and
you've got a few weeks left to make your
charitable donations before we close the
books on 2020.
this is why i encourage you to check out
givewell.org for more than 10 years
givewell.org has helped donors find the
charities and projects that save
and improve lives most per dollar here's
how
givewell dedicates more than 20 000
hours a year to researching charitable
organizations
and handpicks a few of the highest
impact evidence-backed
charities i recommend givewell.org and
they shared a note with me
which is just incredible and here it is
quote here are the data they sent me a
spreadsheet
we have from organic donations that
cited tim over the past few years
transactions that specifically cited tim
ferriss sum to 133
040.74 we estimate that those donations
will save
15 to 24 lives how did this happen
i suspect that a lot of these donations
came from my interview with will
mccaskill who really knows what he's
talking about when it comes to effective
giving he's a philosopher
ethicist and one of the originators of
the effective altruism movement
he is an associate professor in
philosophy at oxford
that is the university of oxford and a
researcher at the global priorities
institute at oxford just a great guy
overall
and in our podcast together he
recommended givewell
by far as one of the best places to give
if you want to make an impact especially
if
you're busy it came to his mind
immediately all of their research is
publicly available for free
on their website and more importantly
givewell never takes any fees so all of
your tax deductible donations are given
to the charity you
choose since 2010 givewell has helped
more than 50
000 donors direct more than 500 million
dollars
to the most effective charities these
donations will save more than 75 000
lives
and improve the lives of millions more
so if you want to have
the best bang for buck each dollar you
put in has the greatest impact
this is just one of the fastest easiest
ways to hone in
on the best options the highest leverage
options
this year you can support the charities
that save and improve lives most with
give well if you want your donation to
have even more
impact you can act soon any of my
listeners that's you guys
who become new give well donors will
have their first donation matched up to
250
when you go to givewell.org tim
and select podcast and tim ferriss at
checkout this matching offer
is good for as long as the funds last
could go quickly
so check it out this is a special chance
for even a small donation to make a big
impact
get your first donation matched up to
250
when you go to givewell.org
tim and select podcast in tim ferriss at
checkout one more time
definitely check it out givewell.org
time
you